Hey everybody, how are you? How are you guys? Guess what it is? It's spring break for us. It is spring break for our kids. And you guys, we are gonna go have some family time. That means this week we're doing a rerun, but don't get mad cause it's a really, really good one. Yes, we were just thinking you guys just listened to Dinner Party, right? If you're listening along. And what other epic episode could we play for you? But Booz Cruise! And Booz Cruise is special because this was back when we were recording in the studio and we had our showrunner, Greg Daniels, sit with us for the entire breakdown of the episode. Oh my gosh, he just gave us so much amazing
大家好，你们好吗？大家身体都好吗？猜猜这是什么？对我们来说这是春假。对我们的孩子们来说这是春假。各位，我们要去享受一些家庭时光了。这意味着这周我们要播出一期重播，但别生闷气，因为这期真的非常、非常棒。没错，我们刚刚在想，大家刚才是不是听过了《晚宴派对》，对吧？如果你一直在听的话。还有什么史诗级的剧集能放给你们听呢？那就是《游船派对》！而《游船派对》很特别，因为那是我们以前在录音室录制的时期，当时我们的剧集运作人格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）和我们坐在一起，对整集进行了深入的剖析。哦，天哪，他真的给了我们太多精彩的
insight. We really, truly were like, Greg, can you please come every week? Can you come and sit in this room with us every week? He was so fantastic. We love this episode. We hope you guys enjoy it. And we're gonna be back refreshed. Tons of kid time. We're gonna make lots of snacks. We're gonna play board games. And we're gonna see you in a week. We'll see you in a week, guys. Enjoy! I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes
见解。我们真的、真心觉得，格雷格，你能不能每周都来？你能不能每周都来和我们一起坐在录音室里？他太棒了。我们很喜欢这一集。希望大家也会喜欢。我们要去休假充电啦，回来后会焕然一新。有大量的陪伴孩子的时间。我们要做好多零食。我们要玩桌游。我们一周后见。一周后见，各位。尽情享受吧！我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重播播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并带来独家幕后
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. We're gonna booze it up today. It is the booze cruise episode, everybody. Are you running a party? Season two, episode 11, written by Greg Daniels, directed by Ken Quapas. Angela's been on a booze cruise. In the Cayman Islands. Ooh, I've been on a booze cruise of Lake Ozark, Missouri. That's the one I want to go on. Oh yeah, live band, all of it. Very similar. Okay, let's get into this. Let's get into it. I will start with a summary. I feel like this episode doesn't need it, but I'm gonna give one anyway. Michael takes The Office on a booze cruise of Lake Wallin Pawpack. So corporate won't pay for
故事，只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》的女士们。我们今天要开怀畅饮了。大家注意，这就是游船派对那一集。你在办派对吗？第二季第十一集，格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·夸帕斯导演。安吉拉去过游船派对。在开曼群岛。哦，我去过密苏里州奥沙克湖的游船派对。那是我最想去的一个。哦，对，有现场乐队，什么都有。非常相似。好了，我们进入正题吧。我们开始吧。我先来做个总结。我觉得这一集其实不需要总结，但我还是要做一个。迈克尔带着《办公室》的员工去沃林帕帕克湖参加游船派对。因为总公司不肯再为
any more parties. But Michael found a loophole. As long as he calls it a leadership training exercise, then corporate will endorse it. So that's what he does. But it's really just an excuse for a party. Michael loves a party. All right, let's jump in with fast fact number one. Booze cruise was the first episode to air on Thursday nights. Yeah, this was a huge deal. This was a huge deal for us. Must-see TV lineup. We were so giddy about this. We were so excited. I wrote a whole MySpace blog about it. I was so happy. I did too. Yeah. Announcing our move to Thursday nights because I don't know if people know, but we started on Tuesday nights at 9.30. And now we were
任何派对买单了。但迈克尔找到了一个漏洞。只要他把这称作领导力培训活动，总公司就会批准。所以他就这么做了。但这其实只是办派对的借口。迈克尔最爱办派对。好了，让我们直接来看第一个冷知识。《游船派对》是第一首在周四晚间播出的剧集。对，这可是件大事。这对我们来说是件大事。必看电视黄金档。我们对此兴奋得头晕目眩。我们太激动了。我为此写了一整篇MySpace博客。我太高兴了。我也是，对。宣布我们转移到周四晚间播出，因为我不知道大家知不知道，我们一开始是在周二晚上9点半播出的。而现在我们要
moving to the Thursday must-see TV lineup. This was a coveted time slot, you guys. It's where friends was. It was a big, big deal. It still is. It's still their big night of comedy. Yeah. So we felt like we'd really made it. And also, this is a fan question from Sean Anaya. In episode two of the podcast, Angela mentioned that she and the other supporting cast members became series regulars during the booze cruise. Yes. Angela, how did that feel? It was such an exciting time, Jenna, because our agents called us and said, hey, they want to make you series regulars. We were all so, so excited. It also meant that maybe we wouldn't get fired. Now, did that happen in the middle of filming booze cruise
转到周四的必看电视黄金档了。各位，这是一个令人垂涎的黄金时段。那是《老友节》（注：原文如此，即《老友记》）播出的地方。这可是一件天大的事。现在依然如此。这依然是他们盛大的喜剧之夜。所以我们觉得自己真的是熬出头了。另外，这是一个来自肖恩·阿纳亚的粉丝提问。在播客的第二集里，安吉拉提到她和其他配角演员是在拍摄《游船派对》期间成为了常规演员。是的。安吉拉，当时感觉怎么样？那真是一个令人兴奋的时刻，珍娜，因为我们的经纪人打电话给我们说，嘿，他们想让你们成为常规演员。我们当时都兴奋极了。这也意味着也许我们不会被炒鱿鱼了。那么，这发生在拍摄《游船派对》的
or at the beginning? What was the timing? In the middle. We were on the boat. I remember we were on the boat when I got the call saying that NBC would like for you to be series regulars and you're going to have like an extended contract. You're not going to be a week-to-week day player. Oh my gosh. We were all talking. We were also excited, the supporting cast. You and I, we had a break where we got to go off the boat, but we're standing right by the boat, Jenna. We're right by the boat. And I gave Oscar Nunez my camera and I said, Oscar, I want you to capture this moment. You and I had been jumping up and down holding hands screaming because we were so excited. Oh, and you have that photo? I have the photo
中间还是开始的时候？时间点是怎样的？在中间。我们在船上。我记得当我在船上接到电话时，NBC希望你们成为常规演员，你们将获得延长合同。你们不再是那种一周一签的临时演员了。哦，天哪。我们都在聊天。配角演员们都兴奋极了。你和我，我们有一个间隙可以下船，但我们就站在船边，珍娜。我们就站在船边。我把我的相机交给奥利弗·努涅斯（注：应为奥斯卡·努涅斯），我说，奥斯卡，我需要你捕捉这个瞬间。你和我一直在手拉着手又蹦又跳地尖叫，因为我们太兴奋了。哦，你有那张照片吗？我有那张照片
and you and I look insane because we're so tired. We're tired and we're mid-jumping up and air holding hands like two school girls. And Oscar was like, oh, you two are so silly. And he gave us a big hug. But this was job security. Yeah. And this, yes, this was like we all knew now. One, our show must be doing well because now they're going to pay us all to be here all the time. Yeah. And then we knew we had a job. Special, special. I know. Things are starting to turn now. We've been talking about how we were really wondering week to week if we had jobs and now we're starting to feel like, oh, we're on a TV show that's going to keep coming back. Now, we still haven't been picked up for season three yet,
而且你和我都看起来疯了，因为我们太累了。我们又累又处于腾空跳跃状态，像两个女学生一样手拉着手。奥斯卡就说，哦，你们两个太傻了。然后他给了我们一个大大的拥抱。但这代表了工作保障。对。而且这个，是的，这就好像我们大家都知道了。第一，我们的节目肯定表现不错，因为现在他们要付钱让所有人都一直呆在这里了。是的。然后我们知道我们有工作了。特别，特别。我知道。事情现在开始转变了。我们一直在谈论我们曾经如何一周又一周地担心自己是否还有工作，而现在我们开始觉得，哦，我们正在参与一个会不断回归的电视节目。现在，我们还没有续签第三季，
but we know, okay, we at least have a job for like another 13 weeks at this point. Yeah. This was the most job security any of us had had since the beginning of the show. Oh, yeah. Yeah. For sure. For sure. All right. Fast fact number two, let's talk about our guest stars. Big, big guest stars. First up, this is the third and final appearance of Amy Adams as Katie. Now, I went back and I was looking at the timeline. She had not yet been nominated for her Academy Award for Junebug. That happened just a couple weeks after we finished filming this episode, but there was a ton of buzz. There was a lot of buzz that she was going to be an Oscar contender. And it was just so wonderful knowing her the way we did at
但我们知道，好吧，至少我们目前还有大约13周的工作。对。这是自节目开播以来，我们所有人获得的最大工作保障。哦，是的。是的。肯定的。肯定的。好了。冷知识之二，我们来谈谈客串明星。大牌，绝对的大牌。首先，这是艾米·亚当斯第三次也是最后一次饰演凯蒂。现在，我回过头去看了看时间线。她当时还没有因《甲虫箱》（注：即《六月炽热》）获得奥斯卡提名。那是在我们完成这集拍摄几周后才发生的，但当时已经有了大量的造势。有很多人在传她会成为奥斯卡奖的竞争者。考虑到我们当时对她的了解，以及她一直以来都是一个努力工作的女演员，这种感觉真的很奇妙。有些事情对她很有利。有些事情则没有。看到她身边围绕着这种充满活力的氛围，而她又是如此谦逊、甜蜜、善良的一个人。你真的忍不住会为她加油。我记得当时为她感到非常高兴和充满希望。在这一集的大部分拍摄中，我都坐在她旁边。我们在拍摄过程中成了非常好的朋友。我们分享了彼此的生活、希望和梦想。她真的是一个非常坦诚、温暖、慷慨的人。然后，你知道的，这艘船是一艘没有任何豪华设施的船。没有豪华设施。这船上没有豪华设施。好吧。是的。我们在拍摄间隙就睡在那些长椅上，而她
this point and knowing that she had just been a hard working actress. Some things had gone her way. Some things hadn't. And to just sort of see this electricity around her and she is just such a humble, sweet, kind person. You just can't help but root for her. And I remember being so happy for her and hopeful. I was seated next to her for pretty much most of the work in this episode. And we just became such good friends doing this. We shared so much about our lives and our hopes and our dreams. And she was just a very open, warm, generous person. And then, you know, this boat was no frills. No frills. No frills on this boat. Okay. Yeah. We were just sleeping on those benches between takes and she was
完全融入其中。本集的另一位大牌客串明星是饰演杰克船长的罗布·里格尔（Rob Riggle）。里格斯。好的。关于罗布的一些事实，以防大家不知道，他是一名真正的美国海军陆战队退伍军人。他于1990年加入海军陆战队，最初的打算是成为一名海军飞行员，但后来他离开去追求喜剧事业了。是的。喜剧。对。但他一直留在海军陆战队预备役，直到2013年服役23年后退役。我的意思是，这，他是来真的。他是来真的，而且这个人有着一颗热爱服务的心。你和他一起打过垒球。我打过。他是其中一员。他是儿童慈悲医院（Children's Mercy Hospital）的志愿者之一，罗布对我的启发真的很大。好吧，大家可能也从
all in. Another big guest star from this episode is Rob Riggle as Captain Jack. Riggs. All right. So a few facts about Rob, in case people don't know, he is a real Marine Corps veteran. He joined the Marines in 1990 with the intention of becoming a naval aviator, but then he left to pursue comedy. Yeah. Comedy. Yeah. But he stayed a member of the Marine Corps Reserves until he retired in 2013 after 23 years of service. I mean, this is, he's the real deal. He is the real deal and the man has such a heart for service. You do the softball game with him. I do. He's one of the people. He's one of the people for Children's Mercy Hospital and Rob is just an inspiration to me. Well, you guys out there might recognize him also
《周六夜现场》（SNL）或《每日秀》（担任军事记者）中认出他，或者从无数电影中认出他，包括与安吉拉·金西合作的《毛茸茸的复仇》。他出演了《毛茸茸的复仇》，然后你们肯定认不出他在福克斯电视台和我一起拍过的一部试播集《盖布瑞尔一家》（The Gabriels），这部剧从未见天日，我们在里面扮演夫妻。我们当时玩得太开心了。我一直跟他说，我说，罗布，总有一天我们还要演夫妻。哦，我很想看到那个。你们俩一定会很棒。是的。所以你认识他，你是他的朋友。是的，我们是好哥们。所以我昨天给他打电话，他简直是世界上最忙的人。我当时问，罗布，你在哪儿？你在洛杉矶吗？因为我上一次跟他说话的时候，
from SNL or from the Daily Show where he played their military correspondent or from like a gazillion movies, including Furry Vengeance with Angela Kinsey. He was in Furry Vengeance and then you won't recognize him from a pilot he and I did called the Gabriel's on Fox that never saw the lie today where we played husband and wife. We had so much fun. I keep telling him, I'm like, Rob, someday we're going to get to play husband and wife again. Oh, I would love to see that. You guys would be great. Yeah. So you know him, your friends with him. Yes, we are pals. So I called him yesterday and he's like the busiest guy ever. I was like, Rob, where are you? Are you in Los Angeles? Because the last time I talked
他在苏格兰。哦，他在搞一些非常有趣的事情。但我跟他聊了聊，我说，罗布，你对杰克船长和整集《游船派对》有什么印象？他是这么说的。好吧。他说，从我个人的角度来看，这是我离开《周六夜现场》之后接到的第一批工作之一。我当时紧张极了。我真的很嫩，而且没怎么在镜头前表演过。我很害怕，我想把工作做好，因为我太喜欢这个节目了，而且这个角色太有趣了。他还说，他真的很喜欢我们在水上拍摄，而且这是一场夜戏。他说，你知道的，我不知道你记不记得，但在两场戏之间，没有人可以退回到自己的
to him, he was in Scotland. Oh, he's like doing some really fun stuff. But I talked to him and I was like, Rob, what do you remember about Captain Jack and the whole booze cruise episode? And this is what he said. Okay. He said, well, and on a personal level, it was one of the first jobs I had after leaving Saturday Night Live. I was so nervous. I was really green and I hadn't done much in front of a camera. I was scared and I wanted to do a good job because I loved the show so much and the character was so much fun. He also said he really enjoyed that we shot on the water and that it was a night shoot. And he said, you know, and I don't know if you remember this, but no one could retreat to
化妆车里。你无处可去。所以我们整晚都挤在那条船上。我们坐在卡座里闲聊，人们会在不同的场景之间串卡座。你会遇到一些人说：“哦，去和约翰、珍娜、艾米·亚当斯以及大卫·德曼聊聊吧。”“哦，去和会计们聊聊吧。”你知道的，所以他说，太有趣了。我们会串卡座，大家都在一起玩。我真的觉得那天晚上我认识了一些人。他说的第二件事是，他觉得对不起史蒂夫，因为史蒂夫一整天都在拍摄《冒牌天神2》（Evan Almighty）。然后他还要赶到我们的片场拍夜戏。但尽管史蒂夫那么累，他
their trailers between scenes. You had nowhere to go. So we all hung out in that boat all night. We sat in the booths and hung out and people would sort of booth hop between scenes. You would have people that would like, Oh, let's go talk to John and Jenna and Amy Adams and David Denman. Oh, let's go talk to the counting. You know, and so we, he said it was so fun. We would booth hop and everyone would hang out. And I really felt like I got to know some people that night. The second thing he said was he felt really bad for Steve because Steve was shooting Evan Almighty all throughout the day. And then he would come over to our set and film throughout the night. But even though Steve was so tired, he was
依然善良、体贴且专业。他说史蒂夫真的成为了他工作伦理上的灵感来源。现在，如果你了解罗布，你就知道他有惊人的工作伦理，但他确实在史蒂夫身上看到了这一点。好吧。所以他说的第三件事是，他说：“安吉，这事会纠缠我。它已经纠缠我14年了。”他说：“我得说‘沃林帕帕克湖’（Lake Wallenpaupack）。”他说：“安吉，你刚听清我是怎么说的吗？沃林帕帕克湖。我说得就像它直接从我嘴里溜出来一样。就像我在那里长大的一样。”是的。他说：“我就是说不对。”他说：“我甚至不知道他们有没有拍到能用的镜头。”他说：“我可能连续说错了10遍。”他说：“我开始出汗了。我太尴尬了。”他
still kind and thoughtful and professional. And he said that Steve really became an inspiration for him for work ethic. Now, if you know Rob, you know, he has an amazing work ethic, but he really saw that in Steve. Okay. So the third thing he said, and he was like, Ange, this is going to haunt me. It's haunted me for 14 years. He said, I had to say Lake Wall and Pawpack. And he said, Ange, did you just hear how I said that? Lake Wall and Pawpack. I said it like it just rolled off my tongue. Like I grew up there. Yeah. He said, I could not get it. He said, I don't even know if they had a usable take. He said, I must have messed it up 10 times in a row. He said, I started sweating. I was so embarrassed. He
说：“我就是说不出‘沃林帕帕克湖’。”他说，当他的拍摄结束开车回家时，他从长滩开回家的路上，大概一个半小时的车程，他一直在念叨：“沃林帕帕克湖，沃林帕帕克湖，帕帕克。”他说，他在车里开着车回家的路上说得一点问题都没有。他说，但在镜头前就是说不出来。他说，这已经纠缠我14年了。罗布，我爱你。我知道。各位一定要去收看罗布·里格尔在探索频道的新节目，3月8日开播。节目叫《全球调查员》（Global Investigator）。他还想让我告诉大家，这个节目将在《原始生活21天》（Naked and Afraid）之后播出。我说，好吧，罗布，这可是个好档期。
said, I could not say Wall and Pawpack. And he said, when his, when his like shoot was done and he was driving home, all he did on his drive home from Long Beach, it was like, you know, an hour and a half drive. He was like, Lake Wall and Pawpack, Wall and Pawpack, Pawpack. He said, I could say it with no problem in my car driving home. He said, but I could not say it in the take. And he said, and it's haunted me for 14 years. Rob, I love you. I know. And you guys be sure to check out Rob Riggle's new show on the Discovery Channel is starting March 8th. It's called Global Investigator. And he wanted me to let you guys know that it's going to air after naked and afraid. I said, well, Rob, that's a lead
罗布太棒了。我非常喜欢他。非常感谢你，罗布。哦，太棒了。情报不错，安吉。所以我们在这一集里还有另一位客串明星。布伦达·威瑟斯（Brenda Withers）饰演布伦达，公司派来的联络员，被派到游船上监视迈克尔。关于布伦达有一些有趣的冷知识。让我们，让我们听听看。布伦达·威瑟斯和敏迪·卡灵在《办公室》之前是一个编剧组合。她们在一个外百老汇话剧《马特和本》（Matt and Ben）中担任编剧和演员，该剧讲述了马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克的友谊，她们在剧中分别饰演马特和本。是的。布伦达饰演马特，敏迪饰演本。故事背景设定在1995年，讲述了马特和本在成名之前在公寓里幻想自己成名的故事。
man. Rob is fantastic. And I adore him. Thanks so much, Rob. Oh, that was amazing. Good intel, Ange. So we have yet another guest star on this episode. Brenda withers plays Brenda, the corporate liaison sent on the booze cruise to keep tabs on Michael. And there's some fun facts about Brenda. Let's, let's hear them. Brenda and Mindy Kaling were a writing team before the office. They wrote and performed in an off Broadway play called Matt and Ben, which was about the friendship of Matt Damon and Ben Affleck. And they played Matt and Ben. Yes. Brenda played Matt and Mindy played Ben. It was set in 1995 and it tells the story of Matt and Ben before they were stars in their apartment, fantasizing about being famous.
这是一个巨大的成功。这是一部轰动一时的评论界热门作品。我很想看看那部剧。我查了一下《纽约时报》的评论，简直是赞不绝口。这确实让她们崭露头角。这也是让敏迪受到关注的关键。我们甚至还没聊到这个。我们甚至都没提到今天谁要来节目。我知道。我正准备顺口说出来，就好像我们已经宣布过了一样。我知道。我也想过这个。然后我想，等等，我们甚至都没说。各位，我们今天有一位超级巨大、超级棒、所有嘉宾中的大咖要来！节目的创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯今天要来参与我们的节目。他随时都会到这里。他要和我们坐在一起。正如你所看到的，我们有点
It was a huge hit. It was a smash critical hit. I would have loved to see that. I looked up the New York Times review and it was just glowing. And this really put them on the map. And it's, it's definitely what got Mindy noticed. We haven't even talked about this. We haven't even mentioned who's coming on the show today. I know. I was just about to let it roll off my tongue as if we had announced it. I know. I thought about it too. And I was like, wait, we didn't even say. You guys, we have an amazingly huge, awesome, the guest of all guests is on today. Greg Daniels, the creator of the show is coming on the episode today. He's going to be here any minute. He is going to sit with us. We're, we're a little
兴奋过头了。我们超级兴奋。我深信他是去看了那出戏，然后才发掘了敏迪的。是的，我们得问问他。我们会问他的，因为他马上就到了。因为他就要来了。是的，没错。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，《办公室》的剧集运作人兼本集的编剧，将加入我们。这太搞笑了。我们怎么没有以此作为开场呢？这简直是喧宾夺主。我想我们只是太激动了。我知道我一直在看表，因为他很快就要到了。所以我说，哦，快把冷知识讲完吧。因为格雷格等会儿就要来了。哦，就快点讲冷知识吧。好啦，快点把你的冷知识讲完。我有个好建议。不，我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。好了。
giddy as you can tell. We're super giddy. And I believe he went and saw the show and that's how he discovered Mindy. Yeah, we'll have to ask him. We'll ask him because he'll be here. Because he's going to be here. Yes, that's right. Greg Daniels, showrunner of the office and writer of this episode will be joining us. That's hilarious. Why did we not lead with that? Talk about burying the lead. I think we're just so excited. I know I'm watching the clock because he's going to be here soon. So I was like, oh, let's get fast facts done. Cause then Greg's going to be here. Oh, just get fast facts. Hey now, hurry up and get your fast facts. I had a good tip. No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. All
好吧，让我们讲完这些冷知识，好让格雷格能进来。冷知识。第三个，我们在实景拍摄，各位，在船上，在船上，在船上。拍摄地点在长滩港外，距离洛杉矶南部约45分钟车程。我们在那里拍了三天。其中两天我们在船停靠时进行拍摄。然后有一天晚上我们在移动，因为我们在长滩，他们把我们安排在一家酒店。我曾经有过一些宏大的幻想，觉得我们会在酒店里一起闲逛，然后开开派对什么的。我不知道。我有这种想法。我以前从没真正在外景地拍过戏。我们甚至都没见过那家酒店。我们简直是整晚都在
right. Well, let's finish with these fast facts so that Greg can get in here. Fast fact. Number three, we shot on location guys on a boat, on a boat, on a boat. This was outside of the Long Beach Harbor, which is about 45 minutes south of Los Angeles. We shot there for three days. Now for two of the days we filmed while the boat was docked. And then there was one night when we were moving because we were in Long Beach and they put us up at a hotel. I had these grand fantasies that we were going to be all hanging out back at the hotel and like kind of partying or something. I don't know. I like have this idea. I've never really been on location before. We never even saw the hotel. Literally we're on the
船上，然后去酒店可能睡上几个小时，接着就马上回去了。我对酒店完全没有记忆。没有，但我，我确实带了扑克筹码，以为我们会在酒店闲逛打扑克，但那从来没有发生过。我们实际上是从下午晚些时候一直拍到通宵，直到太阳升起。是的。我在日记里写道，我们从下午2点半开始拍，通常到早上5点左右收工。我还写道，接下来的那一整周，我都能感受到那艘船的摇晃。我在杂货店排队时意识到自己还在摇晃。哦，天哪。这太强烈了，因为即使船没有开，你依然在水面上。哦，是的，其实我觉得停泊的时候更糟糕，因为那样它就会做这种诡异的、一点点、一点点、一点点、一点点的晃动。而当船在开的时候，你知道的，会好一些。那是一种向前的运动，但这种靠在码头上连续好几天的摇晃。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
boat all night and we would go to the hotel and maybe sleep a few hours and then we'd go right back. I have no memory of the hotel. No, but I, I did bring poker chips thinking that we would hang out at the hotel and play poker, but it never happened. We actually filmed from like late afternoon overnight until the sun came up. Yes. I wrote in my journal that we filmed from 2.30pm and usually wrapped around 5am. And I wrote, I felt the motion of that boat all week the next week. I would be in line at the grocery store and realize I was swaying. Oh my gosh. It was intense because even when the boat wasn't moving, you're still on water. Well, yeah, even I actually think it's worse when you're just
这勾起了你的回忆。我有几张来自这一集的精彩照片，因为我带了相机，我那部老式相机。我刚才提过了，当我得知自己成为常规演员时拍了一张照片，但我全程把它带在船上。所以我有，我有很多。我看着我所有的办公室照片，我所有的纪念品，《游船派对》占了很大一部分照片。我带了摄像机。那时候我们船上没有iPhone，但我有一个小摄像机，我把我们所有的幕后花絮都拍了下来。我记得这个。一个关于《游船派对》的纪录片，你可以在YouTube上找到它。如果你去YouTube搜索珍娜·费舍尔《游船派对》纪录片，它就会弹出来。太棒了。我采访了剧组成员。我问他们是做什么的，这非常搞笑，因为你可以看到我们登船的情景。我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，我把所有的素材都给了他，他剪辑了这段视频。
docked because then it's like doing this weird like a little, like a little, little, little, little, little kind of thing. And when you're moving, you know, it's better. It's like a forward motion, but that kind of rocking against the dock for days on it. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Let's bring you back memories. I have some fantastic photos from this episode because I brought my camera, my old school camera. I already mentioned we got a photo when I found out I was serious regular, but I had it on the boat with me the whole time. So I have, I have so many. I was looking at all my office photos, all my memorabilia and Booze Cruise is a huge chunk of photos. I brought my camcorder. Back then we didn't have iPhones
你可以看到我们所有人都登上了船。我们当时喊着，耶，游船派对。然后第一天我们喊着，耶，游船派对。我们还在继续，我们还在拍，到了第三天。没有人跟我说话，但你绝对能看到整个过程的发展。我看完整部片子，它让我笑了。天哪，它直接把我带回了过去。而且我们当时看起来像12岁。确实。我们看起来太……我说，哦，天哪，岁月已经在我的脸上留下了痕迹。哦，不。我说，哇，我们看起来太年轻了。好吧，我全讲完了。我们去把格雷格叫进来，一起剖析这一集吧？好啊，因为我有一堆记事卡。你真的有。我真的有。
on this boat, but I had a little camcorder and I filmed all of us behind the scenes. I remember this. A documentary of Booze Cruise, which you can find on YouTube. If you go on YouTube and like Jenna Fisher, Booze Cruise documentary, it'll pop up. It's amazing. I interviewed crew members. I asked them what they did and it's very funny because you see us getting on the boat. Dave Rogers, our editor, I gave him all the footage and he put together this video. You see us all getting on the boat. We're like, yeah, Booze Cruise. And then the first night we're like, yeah, Booze Cruise. We're still, we're doing it. We're doing it like by the third night. No one will speak to me, but you definitely see
这几位来得很早，因为我有太多的卡片要摆出来，她当时就说，我进来的时候吓了一跳。我说，这是什么？不过都在这儿了。好吧，那就开始吧。好的，各位，我们结束了休息，现在正和《游船派对》的编剧、《办公室》的剧集运作人格雷格·丹尼尔斯坐在一起。格雷格，非常感谢你抽空前来。哦，非常感谢你们邀请我。我非常喜欢你们的节目。你们两个在一起太棒了。听你们聊天非常有娱乐性，对我来说，听到你们的声音、观点以及一切，真的太有趣了。非常感谢你，格雷格。如果没有你，格雷格，我们就不会成为最好的朋友，这个节目也不会存在。我们的人生将完全，我甚至不知道，老实说，我简直无法用言语表达，因为现在我要情绪激动了。我来了。我已经，我不行了，对不起。我刚才突然百感交集。你知道吉姆是怎么说的吗？他说他敢打赌迈克尔在这集里一定会做
the progression. I watched the whole thing and it just made me smile. I just, man, it just brought me right back. And we also look 12 years old. We do. We just look so, I was like, oh man, time has marched on across my face. Oh no. I was like, wow, we look so young. Well, that's all I've got. Should we go get Greg and bring him in here and break down this episode? Yes, because I have a ton of note cards. You really do. I really do. The guys got here early because I had so many cards to lay out that she was like, I came in and I was shocked. I said, what is this? Here it is though. All right, well, let's do it. Okay, guys, we're back from our break and we are sitting here with Greg Daniels,
《泰坦尼克号》的那个动作？是的，我本以为安吉拉会哭出来的。结果已经发生了。发生得太快了。我知道，对不起。我只是，那股感激之情像海潮一样向我涌来，我对你充满感激，我心中只有绝对的感激。彼此彼此。这对我们所有人来说都是一段美好的时光，如果你们的友谊是其中唯一的收获，那也很酷。然而不仅于此，不是吗？我知道。好吧，格雷格，每当有嘉宾来时，我们总是喜欢先问他们：你是怎么加入《办公室》的？你是如何为美国电视开发《办公室》的？我要稍微倒回一点，因为当这个节目开始时，我的职业生涯其实已经起步了。你当时有着非常成功的
writer of Booze Cruise, showrunner of the office. Greg, thank you so much for coming in. Well, thank you so much for inviting me. I love your show. You guys are so good together. It's so entertaining to hear you and it's so fun for me to hear your voices and your points of view and everything. Thank you so much, Greg. If not for you, Greg, we would not be best friends and this show wouldn't exist. Our lives would be completely, I don't even know, I can't even put it into words, honestly, because now I'll get emotional. Here I go. I'm already, I can't, sorry. I just all kind of hit me. Do you know how Jim says he'll bet a paycheck that Michael in this episode is going to do the Titanic
职业生涯，格雷格。我的意思是，你做过《山丘之王》（King of the Hill）。我不会一一列举你的IMDB履历，但你可是货真价实的业内大咖。请继续。我对它还不够了解。你创作了《山丘之王》。《山丘之王》。而且你当时在运作那部剧。你还给《周六夜现场》和《辛普森一家》写过无数剧本。哦，天哪，《辛普森一家》里有首歌是你写的，简直太棒了。不管怎样，好吧。谁需要快买店？是的，谁需要？没错。好吧。所以你是实打实的业内大咖。当时事业正顺。所以是的。所以我处于一个很好的位置。你知道他们说的吗？就像你需要10,000小时的练习才能精通某样东西？是的。所以我在《辛普森一家》和《周六夜现场》积累了大约10,000小时。然后我在《山丘之王》又积累了大约15,000小时。所以我当时可以说是准备就绪了。
thing? Yeah, I would have said Angel was going to tear up. And it happened already. It happened so soon. I know, I'm sorry. I just, it just all like the wave hit me of just gratitude I have for you, just absolute gratitude in my heart. Likewise. It was a great time for all of us and if your friendship was the only thing that came out of it, that would be cool. And yet it's not, is it? I know. Well, Greg, when we have guests, we always like to start with asking them, how did they end up being on the office? How did you end up developing the office for American television? I will go back a little ways because I was kind of already with a career at the time that the show started. You had a very successful
发生的事情是，我的经纪人寄给我一盘《办公室》的磁带，当时这部剧在那边还相当默默无闻。而且它的名字非常无聊。我当时没看。BBC版本。是的。所以他打电话给我。那是在圣诞节期间，在我们节目开播前大约两年。他说：“好吧，如果你不看的话，我要把它寄给别人了。”我说：“哦，好吧，等等，等等。我今晚就看。”我大概11点左右把它放进机器里，一直熬夜到凌晨3点看完。我觉得它简直太绝了。所以，你知道的，我打电话说：“我真的很想见见这些人。”我一直是个好学生般的角色，你知道的，在我的职业生涯中一直是这样。我总是想和那些我尊敬的人互动，而且，
career, Greg. I mean, you had done King of the Hill. I won't list your IMDB, but you were the real deal. Go ahead. I don't know it enough. You created King of the Hill. King of the Hill. And you were running that show. But you had written on Saturday Night Live and The Simpsons Forever. And oh my gosh, there's that one song that you wrote on The Simpsons that is just amazing. Anyway, okay. Who needs a quickie mart? Yes, who needs? Yes. Okay. So you were the real deal. It was things were cooking. So yeah. So I was in a good position. You know how they say like you need 10,000 hours to be good at something? Yes. So I had sort of 10,000 hours on The Simpsons and Saturday Night Live. And then I had another like 15,000 hours on King of the Hill. So I was like prepared.
你知道的，我卖了一集《宋飛正傳》（Seinfeld）给他们，这样我就能和拉里·戴维（Larry David）合作了。对我来说，那是一个对职业生涯至关重要的举动。我当时认定，瑞奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）和斯蒂芬·莫昌特（Stephen Merchant）做了一件让他们跻身这一行业顶尖人才之列的事情。所以我真的很想见见他们。我其实并不认为这能被改编。所以我当时其实是在“套近乎”。我想：我要去见你们，开个有趣的会。从你们那里偷取知识。问你们问题。以此建立关系。也许为了将来的某个合作。管他呢。不，才不会是这个（指翻拍）。不管怎样，我们在本·西尔弗曼（Ben Silverman）的办公室见了面，因为他拥有版权，我们相处得非常融洽，因为事实证明，他们热爱美国电视，特别是
And what happened was my agent sent me the tape of the office and it was pretty unknown over here. And it had a pretty boring title. And I didn't watch it. The BBC version. Yes. And so he called me. It was over Christmas, like two years before our show came out. And he said, all right, I'm going to send this to somebody else if you don't watch it. And I was like, oh, okay, hang on, hang on. I'll watch it tonight. And I put it in around 11 and I stayed up till like three in the morning watching it. I thought it was just brilliant. So, you know, I called and I said, I really want to meet these guys. And I had been kind of like a good little student, you know, always in my career. And I always wanted to interact with people who I respected. And,
《辛普森一家》，尤其是他们最喜欢的单集，或者说瑞奇最喜欢的单集是《荷马坏小子》（Homer Badman），那集是我写的。所以我们一拍即合。太棒了。我当时在跟他们讲述我关于制作电视节目的各种理论，这些理论是我在制作《山丘之王》时付诸实践的，也就是较慢的节奏，为尴尬感和现实主义留出空间，诸如此类。他们对此产生了强烈的共鸣。所以我们决定，也许我会成为把它改编到美国的人。然后有几个月的时间，我们一直在敲定细节。但一开始的想法始终是把它带到某个很酷的有线电视台，因为这个节目和当时电视上播出的东西完全不同。你知道的，
you know, I sold a episode to Seinfeld so I could work with Larry David. And that was like a career important move for me. And I kind of identified that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant had done something that put them in the top ranks of people working in this profession. So I really wanted to meet them. And I didn't really think it could be adapted. So I was kind of scamming them. I was like, I'm going to go meet you and take this interesting meeting. Take your knowledge from you. Ask you questions. To build a relationship. Maybe for something in the future. Whatever. No, what's not going to be this. And anyway, so we met over at Ben Silverman's office because he had the rights and we got along very well because it turned out that they loved American TV and specifically
我认为当时最大的节目是《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace），那是多机位拍摄、快节奏、远为宽泛的风格。是的，感觉非常不同。是的，没有传统网络电视的那种感觉。是的，感觉很怪异。所以我们在讨论，好吧，也许我们会去HBO，而且显然FX的凯文·赖利（Kevin Reilly）非常喜欢它。所以我们有几种想法。不管怎样，我签约加入了。然后凯文·赖利离开了FX去了NBC，而HBO不想做，因为他们不想做翻拍。本则说：“你必须把这个卖给NBC。”然后我开始非常担心。我就想：这在NBC根本行不通，你知道的，你会觉得：这可不是我签约时想要的。酷炫的有线台节目。是的，完全如此。而且
The Simpsons and specifically their favorite episode or Ricky's favorite episode was Homer Badman, which I had written. And so we kind of hit it off. Amazing. And I was telling them, you know, all the kind of theories that I had about making a TV show that I put into place in King of the Hill, which was, you know, a slower pace and allowing for awkwardness and realism and all this stuff. And it was, they really responded to that. So we decided, well, maybe I would be the person to adapt it into America. And then there was a couple of, you know, months where we were kind of hammering it out. And, but it was always the thought was always to bring it to some place cool and cably because the show was not like what was on TV. You know,
我还会做一些噩梦，梦见自己因为做了这个烂透了的NBC版《办公室》而被全世界的喜剧极客们推上审判台。是的。是的。所以，但最终我们觉得，好吧，也许它的价值在于将电视网络喜剧推向一个新的方向，也许稍微打开一点局面，让它更接近我喜欢的动画片的风格——也就是单机位拍摄，没有罐头笑声之类。所以我当时想：好吧，我可以说服自己仅仅为了这一点也值得去做。而它彻底开创了美国电视的全新类型。好吧，让我们进入《游船派对》。好的，我们开始吧，珍娜。这集的灵感是什么？你知道的，我们当时在做的一件事是，
I think the biggest show at the time was Will and Grace, which was very kind of multi-camera, fast-paced, far more broad. Yeah, very different feel. Yeah, didn't have a network feel of like television. Yeah, it felt weird. And so we were talking about, well, maybe we'll go to HBO and apparently Kevin Reilly at FX really likes it. And so we had a couple of thoughts. And anyway, so I signed on to do it. And then Kevin Reilly left FX and went to NBC and HBO didn't want to do it because they didn't want to do a remake. And Ben was like, you got to sell this to NBC. And then I got very worried. So I was like, this is not going to work on NBC, you know, you're like, this isn't what I signed up for. Cool cable show. Yeah, exactly. And
寻找经典的办公室情境，并测试它们的喜剧潜力。去参加游船派对的想法听起来很有趣。而且这是我们迄今为止最大的一集。你知道，这是我们作为一部剧开始崭露头角的时刻。如果你还记得的话，他们为每个人买了一大堆酒店房间。这有点像是我们将要进行更多实景拍摄的新尝试。这非常令人兴奋。说到游船派对，当我们在船上的时候，我记得我站在你旁边，我告诉你我也去过游船派对，我还做过潜水镜烈酒（snorkel shot），就像我们在那之后聊到的那样。我们当时立刻就把这个拍进去了吗？
and I also had these stress dreams where I would be put on trial by all the comedy nerds in the world for doing this lousy NBC version of the office. Yeah. Yeah. So, but eventually we were like, well, maybe, maybe the value of it will be to move network comedy into a new direction, maybe open it up just a little bit and make it more like what I liked about animation, which was single camera and didn't have a laugh track and stuff like that. So I was like, okay, I kind of convinced myself it was worth doing just for that. And it ushered in this whole new type of American television completely. All right, well, let's get into booze crews. All right, let's do it, Jenna. What was the inspiration for this episode? You know, one of the things we were
没有，没有，没有，我们在。所以我想我们读了，我们进行了剧本围读，我们读了剧本，然后我走到你面前说：“这太棒了。”我说：“你知道吗，我参加过这种派对，而且这太疯狂了。我的意思是，有潜水镜烈酒。”然后你说：“潜水镜烈酒？”你说：“好吧，我想跟你多聊聊潜水镜烈酒。”然后你走开了，我们就像是，只是，你当时在忙着拍摄这一集。这是一集非常大的戏。然后我们在船上。我想你把这个告诉了菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。所以他准备了潜水镜。我只记得突然之间我正在和布莱恩还有奥斯卡聊天，我听到：“安吉拉，安吉拉，过来这里。”原来是你。你说：“过来这里，跟他们讲讲潜水镜烈酒的事。”
doing was we were looking for classic office situations and trying to test them for was their comic potential. And the idea of going on a booze cruise sounded funny. And this was like our biggest episode yet. You know, this was where we were kind of feeling some oats as a show. And if you remember, they bought a whole bunch of hotel rooms for everybody. And this was sort of going to be like the new thing we were maybe going to have more location shooting. And it was very exciting. Speaking of the booze cruise, when we were on the boat, I remember I was standing next to you and I had told you that I had been on a booze cruise and I had done a snorkel shot, like when we were talking about that after that. Did we roll with that right away from that?
我就说：“哦，好吧，你从上面倒进去。”然后你知道的，我们就这样快速上了一堂潜水镜烈酒教程。然后这个情节就进了正片。但这真的太有趣了。我们经常谈论这个，你对那种即兴的合作以及吸收大家的点子是多么开放，这创造了一个多么有趣、超棒的工作环境。是的，完全如此。我很喜欢你们所做的工作。因为，你知道的，我想通过这个节目做的事情之一，就是我在演艺圈经历过、却又不喜欢的事情，大部分都是像工厂流水线生产出来的电视剧，他们把编剧留在这边，
No, no, no, we were. So I think we read, we had the table read, we read the script, and I went up to you and I was like, this is great. I said, you know, I went on one of these and it is, it gets crazy. I mean, there were snorkel shots and you're like snorkel shots and you're like, okay, I want to talk to you more about snorkel shots. And then you kind of went off and we were like, just like, you were busy with the episode. It was a very big episode. And then we were on the boat. And I think you had mentioned it to Phil Shea. And so he had snorkels. And I just remember all of a sudden I was like talking to Brian and Oscar and I heard Angela, Angela, get over here. And it was you. And you're like, get over here and talk to them about snorkel shots.
把演员放在那边，谁也不跟谁说话。他们必须快点把剧本赶出来。这感觉一点也不具有创造性。我真的很想把这一切融合起来，让它有一种更有手作感的气息。所以我让很多编剧参与演戏。我也让一些演员参与写作。我总是喜欢引入你们那种“演员的自我修养”式的工作成果。而且，你知道的，我会抓住任何精彩的即兴发挥，就像雷恩（Rainn）扮演阿米什人那整段，就是从一次即兴发挥中诞生的，如果你还记得的话，当时他在谈论他爷爷的名字。他说德怀特是个精明的阿米什人。然后我们说：“哦！”接着你就顺着演下去了。是的，听起来很有趣。我还记得在选角过程中，比如，你知道的，我们最初
I was like, oh, okay, you pour it at the top. But you know, and so we sort of had this quick snorkel shot tutorial. And then it made it in the episode. But it was just so fun. I always, we talk about this a lot, how you were so open to like, in the moment, like collaboration and getting people's ideas. And it made for such a fun, awesome work environment. Yes, completely. I love the work that you guys did. Because, you know, part of the thing that I wanted to do with the show was, like, the experiences that I'd had that I didn't like in show business were mostly like factory made TV, where they keep the writers over here. And the actors are over here
想要史蒂夫。然后他在艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）加入之前接了另一部剧《快来爸爸》（Come to Papa），我不知道你知不知道这个。是的。所以我们听说，本特别听说史蒂夫在《冒牌天神》里的表现有多棒。他确实有一个令人惊叹的、抢尽风头的时刻，就是作为新闻主播说方言的那段。是的。每个人都知道他，你知道的，真的很棒。而且会是个不错的人选。而我非常注重方法，如你所知。我说：“好吧，听起来不错。首先，我要让选角导演加入进来。”而且我，你知道的，真的很想用艾莉森·琼斯，因为她制作过我非常喜欢的《怪胎与书呆》（Freaks and Geeks）。我们花了两个星期才让她加入。而在那两个星期里，史蒂夫接了那部别的剧。
and nobody talks to each other. And they got to get the scripts out fast. And it didn't feel very creative. And I really wanted to mix it all and have a more handmade feel to it. And so I had, you know, I had a lot of the writers act. And I would ask the some of the actors to write. And I always love to get access to the kind of actor prepares work that you guys did. And, you know, and, and I would hop on any great ad lib, like that whole thing with Rain, being Amish just came out of an ad lib, if you remember, where he was talking about his grandfather's name. And he said Dwight shrewd Amish. And then we were like, Ooh, and then you just ran with it. Yeah, that sounded fun. I also remember in the casting process, like, I, you know, we, we initially
你知道的，这可能……是的，太糟糕了。所以我们随后经历了一个极其漫长的过程，在城里寻找每一个年龄段可能适合迈克尔·斯科特的人选。包括我认识的各种编剧朋友，都被我塞进了候选名单，你知道的，还有一些普通人，就像我走在街上会说：“你看起来不错。读读这段。”是的。但无论如何，事情兜兜转转又回到了原点。经过三个月的紧张选角，我们从凯文·赖利那里得到了一条小线索，说《快来爸爸》可能无法长久。我们可以让史蒂夫在不与那部剧冲突的情况下处于第二选择位置，这样我们就安全了。所以我们进入《游船派对》吧。好吧。好吧。记事卡。记事卡。好吧。好吧。我有个
wanted Steve. And then he took that other show come to Papa before Alison Jones came on board. I don't know if you know that. Yeah. So we had heard Ben had specifically heard about how great Steve was in Bruce Almighty. And he really had that amazing sort of scene stealing moment where he's speaking in tongues as the newscaster. Yes. And everybody knew he was, you know, really great. And would be a good choice for this. And I'm very methodical, as you know. And I was like, Okay, that sounds great. First, I want to get the casting director on board. And I, you know, really wanted to use Alison Jones from her works on Freaks and Geeks, which I love. And it took two weeks to get her on board. And in those two weeks, Steve took this other show.
冷开场。记事卡。哦，等等，我们有记事卡。记事卡。第45秒。哦，是的。是的。是的。很早的一个。我坚信凯文带了一条Speedo泳裤。一条金属蓝的Speedo泳裤和一大堆避孕套。还有一大堆避孕套。是的。还有一大堆避孕套。他还有，我们有一个精彩的吉姆和帕姆的采访镜头，一个联合采访镜头，我知道这对于你们在拍摄前夕来说非常有趣。是的，我们在那段镜头里宣读了迈克尔发给每个人的备忘录，告诉我们要为一次突如其来的郊游做准备。他让我们打包一把牙刷、一件泳衣、一个滑雪面罩，还要穿上你的橡胶底鞋。我喜欢帕姆在听到吉姆这段话时的开心神情。还有，在1分53秒时，请注意我们采访镜头窗户外面那白雪皑皑的斯克兰顿背景。
And you know, it might have been. Yeah, it was awful. So then we went on this incredibly long process of looking at every single person in town who could possibly be in the age range for Michael Scott. And including various writer friends that I had, who I threw into the mix and, you know, just normal normal people like I'd be walking down the street, go, you look good. Read this. Yeah. But anyway, it came full circle. And then after three months of intense casting, we got a little tip off from Kevin Riley that maybe come to papa wasn't going to go the distance. And we could get Steve in second position to that other show and we'd be safe. And so let's get into booze cruise. All right. All right. No card. No card. Okay. Okay. I have
我们会根据季节更换这些背景。我们有一个春季的。我们有夏天和冬天的。所以这就是我们窗外的冬景。那是1月在沃林帕帕克湖。没错。斯坦利说：“1月份的游船派对。”还有，顺便说一句，正如我们所说，虽然我们有点跳跃，但在6分45秒时，当凯文顺着坡道走上船时，他戴着一个滑雪面罩。你在那儿可以看到一个戴着滑雪面罩的人。哦，珍娜，你说的对。他百分之百地照着备忘录做了。等等，好吧，等等。现在，好吧，我们必须把福利送给那些喜欢冷开场背景细节的背景迷们。自动售货机里都有什么？哦，是的。哦，是的。冷开场。吉姆把德怀特的东西塞进了自动售货机。帕姆
a cold open. No card. Oh, wait, we have a no card. No card. Minute 45. Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. An early one. I believe Kevin is packing a speedo. A metallic blue speedo and lots of condoms. And lots of condoms. Yes. And lots of condoms. He's also, we have a great Jim Pam talking head, a joint talking head, which I know was really fun for you guys to do right before that. Yes, where we're reading the memo from Michael that he has sent around telling us to prepare for a surprise outing. He tells us to pack a toothbrush, a swimsuit, a ski mask, and wear your rubber sold shoes. I love how delighted Pam is by Jim and this talking head. And also at one minute, 53 seconds, please notice the winter Scranton backdrop outside of the window of our talking
买下了德怀特的笔筒，字母H就是那个笔筒，笔筒。有人做过深度挖掘。G是德怀特的办公桌名牌。FF是雷恩真正的全家福相框。是的。粉丝提问。汉娜·沃特金斯（Hannah Watkins）问：自动售货机里有一个带框的照片。那是雷恩童年的真实照片吗？那是雷恩的姑妈、叔叔和侄子的照片。是的。我记得雷恩曾带来过一本家庭相册，里面有他住在俄勒冈州的乡下表亲们，我想，这就是他塑造德怀特时的部分灵感来源。为了他的角色。是的。我想我们把它装进了一个框里。是的。哦，太完美了。太棒了。HH是一个订书机。我是迈克尔，格雷格，我可能会把这个名字说错，迈克·利伯thal（Mike Lieberthal）。那是费城人队棒球教练的摇头娃娃。
head. We would change those backdrops seasonally. They were, we had a springtime one. We had a summer and a winter. So this was our winter backdrop out the window. It was January on the Lake Wallin pop back. That's right. Stanley's like a booze cruise in January. And also on that note, like we said, we are jumping ahead, but at six minutes, 45 seconds, when Kevin is walking down the ramp to get on the boat, he is wearing a ski mask. There you see a man in a ski mask. Oh, Jenna, you're right. He followed the memo to a tee. Wait, okay, wait. Now, wait, we do have to give our background people who love the background stuff in the cold open. What all is in the vending machine? Oh, yes. Oh, yes. The cold open. Jim puts Dwight's stuff in the vending machine. Pam
头。我们会根据季节更换这些背景幕。我们有春季的，还有夏季和冬季的。所以这就是我们窗外的冬季背景幕。那是沃林湖的一月。没错。斯坦利就像在一月份参加酒水游轮。另外，正如我们所说，我们跳过了剧情，但在六分四十五秒时，当凯文走下坡道上船时，他戴着滑雪面具。在那里你可以看到一个戴着滑雪面具的人。哦，珍娜，你说的对。他完全照着备忘录做了。等等，好吧，等等。现在，等等，我们确实得提一下那些喜欢片头背景细节的粉丝们。自动售货机里都有什么？哦，是的。哦，是的。冷开场。吉姆把德怀特的物品放进了自动售货机。帕姆
buys Dwight's pencil cup, which is letter H is the pencil, pencil cup. Someone did a deep dive. G is Dwight's desk name plate. FF is a picture frame of Reign's actual family. Yes. Fan question. Hannah Watkins asked, there is a framed picture in the vending machine. Is that a real photo from Reign's childhood? It is a photo of Reign's aunt and uncle and nephew. Yes. Reign had brought in, I remember, a family photo album of sort of country cousins of his that lived in Oregon, I think, and that was part of what he was drawing from for Dwight. For his character. Yes. I think we put it in a frame. Yes. Oh, that's perfect. That's so good. HH was a stapler. I was Mike, Greg, I might say this wrong, Mike Lieberthal. It was a bobblehead of a Philly's baseball coach.
买下了德怀特的笔筒，字母H是铅笔，笔筒。有人进行了深入研究。G是德怀特的桌上名牌。FF是雷恩真正的家人的相框。是的。粉丝提问。汉娜·沃特金斯问，自动售货机里有一个带框的照片。那是雷恩童年的真实照片吗？那是雷恩的叔叔、阿姨和侄子的照片。是的。我记得雷恩带了一本家庭相册来，里面好像是他在俄勒冈州的一帮乡下表亲，我想这也是他塑造德怀特这个角色的灵感来源之一。为了他的角色。是的。我想我们把它装进了一个相框里。是的。哦，那太完美了。太棒了。HH是一个订书机。我是迈克，格雷格，我可能说错名字了，迈克·利伯thal。那是费城人队棒球教练的摇头娃娃。
I don't know. Yes. Well, that's something that you shouldn't really go to me for. I'll tell you that right now. There was, I mean, Phil Shea, who was a brilliant prop master on our show for the whole time of the show, used to go to Scranton and return with truckloads of chachkies from the different businesses and giveaway pens and local sports figure, bobbleheads and stuff. And I think that was on the penguins, maybe. No, he was a Philly's. He's a Philly's? I looked him up. I Googled him. He was a Philadelphia Philly's catcher on their baseball team. And then also Letter J is Dwight's wallet. Yes. And Jim gives Dwight a bag of nickels to get all his stuff back, which I love that detail.
我不知道。好吧。嗯，那真是不该来问我的事。我现在就可以告诉你。那是，我的意思是，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea），他是我们剧组整个拍摄期间非常出色的道具总监，以前经常去斯克兰顿，然后带回整卡车的各种小物件，来自不同的企业，还有赠送的笔、当地体育名人的摇头娃娃之类的。我想那大概是企鹅队的。不，他是费城人。他是费城人吗？我查过他。我谷歌过他。他是他们的棒球队——费城费城人队的捕手。然后还有字母J是德怀特的钱包。是的。然后吉姆给德怀特一袋硬币来拿回他所有的东西，我很喜欢这个细节。
So then we go to the scene where Stanley goes into Michael's office to find out if they will be spending the night. And Michael is so coy and just loves that nobody knows where they're going. And Stanley says, should my wife tell her boss she's not coming in tomorrow? And he's like Stanley, both family, Banana and Anna family, me, my, my man, Lee Stanley. Like, he can't. No. Of course, Stanley can't get anything out because Michael's interrupting him with his ridiculous song. That was also like an early season running joke was him changing people's names. He did, he did it to Pam constantly. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. It's like we kind of dropped that after a few years. He didn't, he didn't really do that to
所以接下来我们来到那个场景：斯坦利走进迈克尔的办公室，想打听他们今晚会不会过夜。而迈克尔表现得非常羞怯，就是喜欢没人知道他们要去哪儿。斯坦利说，我老婆该不该告诉她老板她明天不去上班？而他就好像是，斯坦利，全家，香蕉和安娜一家，我，我，我，我的男人，李·斯坦利。就像，他不能。不。当然，斯坦利什么也套不出来，因为迈克尔一直在用他那荒谬的歌打断他。这也是那种早期剧集的惯用笑话，就是他老是改别人的名字。他这么干，他不断地对帕姆这么干。哦，对。哦，对。就像我们几年后有点放弃这个设定了。他没，他真的不再对
people anymore. All right. So we move into the conference room where Michael finally reveals to everyone that they're going on a booze cruise of Lake Wallinpaw Pack. I became obsessed with the question personally, do they really have booze cruises of Lake Wallinpaw Pack? Yes and no. I did a deep dive on the internet. Okay. So what they mostly have are pontoon boat tours, open-air tours where a guide tells you about the scenery. Well, that boat, the real boat that we filmed on, yeah, was a boat from Long Beach Harbor and was big metal boat. I can't picture how it would have gotten to Lake Wallinpaw Pack, which is, you know, I did a little bit of a deep dive. I think they have like a motor restriction law on Lake Wallinpaw Pack. Yeah. So like you can only have,
大家这么干了。好吧。所以我们转到会议室，迈克尔终于向所有人透露，他们要去沃尔潘帕克湖进行一次酒水游轮派对。我个人对这个问题非常着迷：他们真的有去沃尔潘帕克湖的酒水游轮吗？有也不是。我在网上深入研究了一下。好吧。所以他们大多的其实是浮筒船观光，露天观光，由导游向你介绍风景。好吧，那艘船，我们拍摄时用的那艘真正的船，是的，是长滩港的一艘船，是一艘大的金属船。我无法想象它怎么能开到沃尔潘帕克湖去，你知道的，我稍微深入了解了一下。我想他们在沃尔潘帕克湖有某种限速规定。对。所以就像你只能有，
like, I don't think our boat size would be permitted. Well, supposedly they do have a dinner cruise. So if you're in the area, you can look that up. I'm sure there's beer and wine. I mean, I'm not sure, but. Wait, can we, okay, in the conference room scene, first of all, these are some of my favorite scenes because Michael has something he so desperately is trying to say, and then we just keep interrupting him. Like, I went and looked at the first draft of the episode, and there is a scene that was in the first draft where Brenda, the person from corporate, tells Michael that she hears he's planning this booze cruise, and she tells him that corporate won't pay for it unless it has a certain amount of educational content.
呃，我觉得我们那种船的尺寸是不被允许的。好吧，据说他们确实有晚餐游轮。所以如果你在这个地区，你可以查一下。我敢说肯定有啤酒和葡萄酒。我的意思是，我不确定，但是。等等，我们能，好吧，在会议室的那场戏里，首先，这些是我最喜欢的场景之一，因为迈克尔有一件他拼命想要说的事，然后我们却一直打断他。就像，我去看了这一集的初稿，初稿里有一个场景：布伦达，那个总部来的人，告诉迈克尔说她听说他在筹划这个酒水游轮，并且她告诉他，总部不会为此买单，除非它包含一定量的教育内容。
And he panics because he hadn't prepared anything. And then we go into the conference room scene, and he's trying to make up stuff off Stopper's head. Leader. Ship. It's all about the pause. But we had a very hard time keeping a straight face in the scene, as we often did in conference room scenes. And I caught a few people breaking. Mindy. Mindy at three minutes 41 seconds. When she says I took the tags off already, when she's talking about her bathing suit. Because, you know, Michael says bring a bathing suit, and now she doesn't need one. Mindy puts her hand to her mouth. And that's what she would do when she was about to bring. Mindy was an easy breaker, that's for sure. So easy. Her hair is half up, half down.
而他恐慌了，因为他什么都没准备。然后我们进入会议室的场景，他试图现编现卖，脱口而出。领。导。关键全在于停顿。但在那场戏里，我们很难保持严肃不笑，就像我们在会议室戏里经常做的那样。我抓拍到了好几个人笑场。明迪。明迪在三分41秒的时候。当她说我已经把标签撕掉了的时候，当她在谈论她的泳衣时。因为，你知道的，迈克尔说带件泳衣，现在她不需要了。明迪把手放到嘴边。这就是她快要笑场时会做的动作。明迪是个很容易笑场的人，那是肯定的。太容易了。她的头发半扎半放。
Half up, half down. We're tracking when Kelly is fully Mindy. Yes. Because, Greg, maybe you can shine some light on this. Mindy, the character of Kelly Capour started out as a very kind of like stuffy updo. Her hair was in a bun. She always had paisley top on. That went all the way to her neck. Like an ascot kind of thing. Yes. And then she very slowly just turns into Mindy Kaling. Yes. Basically. And now she's, she, her hair has transitioned. This is a long campaign that Mindy waged behind the scenes. Taking, you know, and I know she plotted it. And every, every step was a victory. And a lot of it would be, we'd kind of do a double take and go, Hey, wait, what, what are you wearing? And she would have,
半扎半放。我们在追踪凯莉完全变成明迪的时刻。是的。因为，格雷格，也许你能解释一下。明迪，凯莉·卡普尔这个角色最初开始时是一种非常古板的盘发。她的头发梳成一个发髻。她总是穿着佩斯利花纹的上衣。那种一直系到脖子的。就像领带结那种。是的。然后她非常缓慢地就变成了明迪·卡灵。是的。基本上。现在她，她，她的头发已经过渡了。这是明迪在幕后发起的一场持久战。她采取了，你知道的，我知道她是精心策划的。每，每一个步骤都是一次胜利。而且很多时候，我们会有点吃惊地回头看，然后说，嘿，等等，你，你穿的是什么？而她会，
she would have slipped something in. Yeah. And she kind of hijacked that character and made it into her character. Well, we're enjoying watching the slow evolution of this. It's been really fun. Yes. I think her hair has now transformed. We're waiting for her wardrobe to transform. And also we're waiting for the first Beyonce reference, which has not happened yet. Well, Brenda also, I don't know. This is maybe, was this a fast fact? Fast fact? I did discuss Brenda in Fast Facts, but we were going to come to you and ask you for your input about Brenda. Well, Brenda was Mindy's writing and performance partner in the play that is how I cast Mindy. Cause Mindy wrote this off-roadway play called Matt and Ben
她会悄悄塞进一些新东西。对。她有点劫持了这个角色，并把它改造成了她自己的角色。好吧，我们很享受看着这个角色的缓慢演变。这真的很有趣。是的。我想她的头发现在已经变了。我们在等待她的衣橱发生转变。而且我们也在等待第一个碧昂丝的梗，这个梗还没出现呢。好吧，布伦达也，我不知道。这也许，这是一个快速事实吗？快速事实？我在“快速事实”里讨论过布伦达，但我们本来打算来找你，问问你对布伦达的看法。好吧，布伦达是明迪在戏剧中的编剧兼表演搭档，我就是通过那部剧选中明迪的。因为明迪写了一部名为《马特与本》的外百老汇戏剧，
about Matt Damon and Ben Affleck writing Goodwill Hunting. And Mindy played Ben Affleck. And her, and Brenda, who's in Booz Crews, played Matt Damon. And it was a hilarious play. You went and saw it? Yes, I went and saw it. By accident or on purpose? No, I was actually, I was a guest of my wife, Suzanne Daniels, who was a network executive, possibly at the WB at that time. I'm not exactly sure where she was working. And she went to see it to do talent scouting. And you went with her? It was super funny. Yeah. And it was great. And then by coincidence, Mindy's spec script came in like the next day for me to read for staffing for writers. And I was like, Hey, wait, that's the one I just saw. Amazing. I would have loved
关于马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克写《心灵捕手》的故事。明迪扮演本·阿弗莱克。而她，还有布伦达，也就是演《酒水游轮》的那位，扮演马特·达蒙。那是一部非常搞笑的剧。你去看过？对，我去看过。是偶然还是故意的？不，其实我是，我是我妻子苏珊·丹尼尔斯（Suzanne Daniels）的嘉宾，她当时是一位电视台高管，可能当时在WB工作。我不确定她当时具体在哪里工作。她去看那部剧是为了物色人才。你跟她一起去的？超级搞笑。对。而且太棒了。然后非常巧合的是，第二天明迪的试写剧本就送到我这儿来了，让我为编剧团队审阅。当时我就想，嘿，等等，这不就是我刚刚看的那部吗？太神奇了。我真希望
to see that. So, so now we have Brenda and she's like the corporate person. You guys, I just have to point out something about Brenda. I know we're not on the boat yet, but Brenda drinks the whole boat ride. She's there to check in on Michael. She has a beer in her hand. You look, look at her scenes on the boat. She has a beer the whole time. She's at the bar. I mean, he only sees her when she's at the bar pretty much. Pretty much. Or she walks up with a beer like to check in on him. Wait, before we get out of the conference room scene, Phyllis broke so hard. Do you remember this? Oh my gosh. So, Michael has said that the sales team could be, is like the furnace of the ship.
能看一看那部剧。所以，所以现在我们有了布伦达，她就像是总部派来的人。伙计们，我必须指出关于布伦达的一点。我知道我们还没上船，但布伦达整段航程都在喝酒。她是来监督迈克尔的。她手里拿着一杯啤酒。你看，看她在船上的那些场景。她全程手里都有一杯啤酒。她在酒吧里。我的意思是，基本上只有当她在酒吧时他才会看到她。差不多。或者她拿着一杯啤酒走过来，就像是去查看他的情况一样。等等，在我们离开会议室的场景之前，菲尔斯笑得太厉害了。还记得吗？哦天哪。所以，迈克尔说过销售团队可以，就像是船上的熔炉。
Keeps things moving along. He compares them to the people from Titanic. Right. Titanic. And at five minutes, 20 seconds, Phyllis has to put her head down because she starts laughing because she says, she asks what the furnace does. And then at five minutes, 50 seconds, she says, everyone in the engine room drown. Do you remember that? She could not get out the word drown. Like she couldn't. She just broke every time. And you can see her like starting to break. That would, that made me break on the day. Yes, me too. When Phyllis was so sadly realized that everyone in the engine room drowned. Well, now let's, we have to have the moment everyone gets on the boat. We've left the conference room. Yes. We're jumping around a little
让事情不断运转。他把他们比作《泰坦尼克号》上的人。对。《泰坦尼克号》。而在5分20秒的时候，菲尔斯不得不把头低下去，因为她开始笑了，因为她说，她问熔炉是做什么的。然后到5分50秒的时候，她说，机舱里的所有人都淹死了。还记得吗？她就是说不出“淹死”这个词。就像她说不出口。她每次都笑场。你能看出她开始笑场了。那，那让我在当场也笑场了。是的，我也是。当菲尔斯那么伤心地意识到机舱里的所有人都淹死的时候。好吧，现在让我们，我们必须经历每个人上船的那个时刻。我们离开会议室了。是的。我们有点跳跃到了
at six minutes, 20 seconds. Michael says that Pam is Mary Ann. Katie and Jim are the Professor and Ginger. Angela's Mrs. Howell. Kelly's the native. Stanley is one of the Globetrotters. Michael is a skipper and Dwight is Gilligan. And this begins the war between Captain Jack and Captain Michael. Yes. I love that Michael has worn his Captain hat to the boost cruise. He has it on in the boost cruise and he still has it on. And now they're having their little power struggle. Who is going to be the boss of this trip? Captain Jack is clearly going to win. I mean, I feel like his boundary is very strong from the beginning. Very strong. And I want you to know. We should say Captain Jack played by Rob Riggle. Yes. Who was a Marine. Who was a Marine.
在6分20秒的时候。迈克尔说帕姆是玛丽·安。凯蒂和吉姆是教授和金杰。安吉拉是豪厄尔夫人。凯莉是土著。斯坦利是哈林环球队员之一。迈克尔是船长，而德怀特是吉利根。这就拉开了杰克船长和迈克尔船长之间的战争。是的。我喜欢迈克尔戴着他的船长帽去参加酒水游轮。他在酒水游轮上戴着它，现在他依然戴着它。然后他们正在进行小小的权力争夺。到底谁才是这次旅行的老板？杰克船长显然会赢。我的意思是，我觉得他的界限从一开始就很明确。非常明确。我想让你们知道。我们应该说杰克船长由罗布·里格尔（Rob Riggle）饰演。是的。他曾是一名海军陆战队员。他曾是一名海军陆战队员。
Yes. Yes. So there's a lot of authenticity to Captain Jack's military bearing there. How did you find Rob? Well, I mean, you know Rob, right? I know Rob. We talked a little bit about it in one of our fast facts, but Rob wanted me to give you a message. Yeah. I talked to him yesterday and he said, thank you so much. Also, he's sorry that he couldn't say like, while I'm popping. Rob was, you know, in the Allison Jones orbit. Yeah. And we certainly knew about him. And I don't know whether he came in for one of the other parts like he might have come in for Dwight or something. I'm not 100% sure. Did that happen sometimes? People who had come in for main cast members, you would ping them for a future episode? Sure. Yeah. I mean, I think
是的。是的。所以杰克船长的军人风范非常有真实感。你是怎么找到罗布的？好吧，我的意思是，你认识罗布，对吧？我认识罗布。我们在其中一个“快速事实”里稍微聊过这个，但罗布想让我带个话给你。对。我昨天和他谈过，他说非常感谢。另外，他很抱歉当时没法说出像“沃尔潘帕克”这样的词。罗布，你知道的，在艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）的交际圈里。对。我们当然知道他。我不知道他是来试镜其他哪个角色，比如他可能来试镜过德怀特什么的。我百分之百不确定。这种事有时会发生吗？对于那些来试镜主要演员的人，你会把他们记下来用于未来的剧集吗？当然。是的。我的意思是，我想
Allison released some of the audition tapes as part of a DVD extra, but there were a lot of cool people that came in. It would have been very interesting to see Seth Rogen as Dwight, for instance. Yes, definitely. Or Kristen Wiig as Pam. I think she came in to read Pam. Yeah. I think she's in my site on my, on my Allison Jones. And Catherine Hawn. Yeah. Allison Jones gave me my sign-in sheet day and Catherine Hawn is on it and Bob Odenkirk is on it. Yeah. Well, Bob was really the number two. If we, if we didn't have Steve, it would have been Bob. He did a great job. And then in season nine, we brought him back as the sort of echo. He was so fantastic too. Yeah. He's great. So I have a lot of fan questions about the boat. Sure. Okay. So since we're getting on
艾莉森把一些试镜带作为DVD花絮发布了，但当时有很多很酷的人来试镜。如果能看到塞斯·罗根（Seth Rogen）饰演德怀特，那会非常有趣，比如。是的，绝对的。或者克里斯汀·韦格（Kristen Wiig）饰演帕姆。我想她是来试读帕姆的。对。我想她在我的，在我的艾莉森·琼斯的名单上。还有凯瑟琳·哈恩（Kathryn Hahn）。对。艾莉森·琼斯给了我当天的签到表，凯瑟琳·哈恩在上面，鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk）也在上面。对。好吧，鲍勃真的是二号人选。如果我们，如果我们没有史蒂夫，那就是鲍勃了。他表现得很棒。然后在第九季中，我们把他带回来作为某种呼应。他当时也太棒了。对。他太棒了。所以关于这艘船，我有很多粉丝的问题。当然。好的。既然我们要上船了，
the boat, Casey Wright asked, was the boat really moving? And Sam Pellet asked how cold it was. The boat was really moving through the water for one of the days of shooting. The other two days, I believe it was docked. And it was cold. It was December 2005, which was chilly, especially at night out on the water. A lot of people wondered, were you pretending to be that cold? I remember being cold. Yes. I don't think there was a lot of pretending. Your cheeks are like quite pink in that scene. Yes. So Lauren Michaels has a thing that he says sometimes where, like, he will get in-character underwear for the actors. Oh. And yeah, I think this is it. And people will say, well, why? Who cares? It's not going to be on camera. And he goes, yes, but the actors know. I kind of get that.
凯西·赖特（Casey Wright）问，船真的在开吗？萨姆·佩莱特（Sam Pellet）问当时有多冷。拍摄的其中一天，船确实在水面上航行。另外两天，我相信它是停泊着的。而且天气很冷。那是2005年12月，很冷，特别是晚上在水面上。许多人在想，你们是假装那么冷吗？我记得当时真的很冷。是的。我觉得没怎么假装。在那场戏里你们的脸颊都红扑扑的。是的。所以洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）有时会说这样的话：他会为演员准备剧中穿的内衣。哦。是的，我想就是这样。人们会说，为什么呢？谁在意呢？又不会拍到镜头里。而他会说，是的，但演员心里知道。我有点懂这个。
Yeah. I kind of get that. And so we certainly believed in that and went out on this real boat in Long Beach Harbor, and it was this huge thing. And to me, the key of it was that romantic scene on the top deck between Pam and Jim. And I just thought it'd be so pretty up there with the twinkling lights of the harbor and the background and everything. So we do that scene. And later in the editing room, somebody was like, what'd you do? Did you just put a row of Christmas lights against a black piece of duvetine there and do it in a studio? And we're like, no. We're on a boat. We're on an actual boat. But it didn't really look that impressive. When it came down to it, it was just this one little twinkle thing of lights on the horizon. Like we could have been on a sound
对。我有点懂这个。所以我们当然相信这一点，开着这艘真正的船来到长滩港，那是一件大事。对我来说，其中的关键是帕姆和吉姆在顶层甲板上的那场浪漫戏。我只是觉得在那上面，伴随着港口闪烁的灯光和背景等等，会非常美丽。所以我们拍了那场戏。后来在剪辑室里，有人问，你们做了什么？你们是不是就在一块黑色的杜维丁绒布前放了一排圣诞彩灯，在摄影棚里拍的？而我们说，没有。我们在船上。我们在真正的船上。但它看起来其实并没有那么令人印象深刻。说到底，它只是地平线上的一小串闪烁灯光。就像我们可以搭个摄影棚一样。
stage. Yeah, we could have been nice and toasty and comfortable. But the wind was blowing, and I don't know. I could tell you're on a boat. I think so. Well, one of the challenges of being on the boat was how sick everyone got. Greg, do you remember that? We were all really sick. Yeah, there was a lot of seasickness. People were really throwing up. I did not get seasick, but do you remember coming up to Kate Flannery and I and saying, hey, you guys, I want to get some b-roll of people vomiting off the side of the boat? Greg, do you remember? I don't, but that would be something I would have done. It was like three in the morning. And you said, so you had Matt Stone grab as many people as he could. And we had the choice of cream of mushroom or menestrone. Oh,
是的，我们可以舒舒服服、暖暖和和的。但风在刮，而且，我不知道。我能看出你们在船上。我也这么觉得。好吧，在船上拍摄的挑战之一就是每个人都晕船晕得厉害。格雷格，你还记得吗？我们都吐得很厉害。是的，很多人晕船。人们真的在呕吐。我没有晕船，但你还记得你走到凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）和我面前说，嘿，伙计们，我想拍一些人们在船舷呕吐的幕后花絮吗？格雷格，你还记得吗？我不记得了，但这确实是我会做的事。当时大概凌晨三点。然后你说，所以你让马特·斯通（Matt Stone）抓了尽可能多的人。我们有蘑菇汤或蔬菜汤可选。哦，
right, right, right. The fake vomiting, yes. The fake vomiting, the fake vomiting. And I did, I did menestrone. Yeah, good choice. But you had to take a swig of it and hold it in your mouth until action and then puke it. And the, I don't know, five to 10 seconds you held it in your mouth was horrible thing because you were just like, like trying not to gag. So I didn't puke for real, but I did fake puke. Well, I got really sick. So did David Denman. And I was wearing those wristbands. Yes. Can we pass out boning too or stuff? Yeah, there was all, there were all these remedies, but nothing really works. Seasickness gum. Someone gave me something to chew on. Maybe the gum. Yeah. There's like a ginger gum. So at one point, the real captain of the boat
对，对，对，对。假装呕吐，是的。假装呕吐，假装呕吐。我选了，我选了蔬菜汤。对，明智的选择。但你得喝上一大口，把它含在嘴里，直到喊“开始”然后吐出来。那，我不知道，含在嘴里的那五到十秒钟是极其可怕的经历，因为你就像是在，努力不让自己作呕。所以我不是真吐，我是假吐。好吧，我病得很厉害。大卫·邓曼（David Denman）也是。我当时戴着那种防晕手腕带。是的。我们能分发晕船药之类的东西吗？对，有各种各样的疗法，但没什么真正管用。晕船口香糖。有人给我什么东西嚼。也许是口香糖。对。有一种姜味口香糖。所以有一次，船上的真船长听说我很难受。船上有三个船长。然后还有，有德怀特在掌舵，还有一个家伙，还有一个真正的船长。有一次，船上的真船长听说我很难受，他拿来一种精油，抹在我耳朵后面。
heard that I was struggling. There were three captains. And then there was also, there was Dwight steering the ship and a guy and then a real guy. At one point, the real captain of the ship heard I was struggling and he got out this oil that he rubbed behind my ears. And about 10 minutes later, I was totally fine. Wow. So I written about this in my diary. I looked it up and I found some on Amazon. Here's what's in it. Here's where we turn this whole thing into an essential oils. By the way, we're sponsored by, sold by Jan. Jan's essential oils and candles. So here's what it has in it. Lavender, peppermint, chamomile, something called Yolang Yolang birch. And then it has frankincense and myrrh. That's the stuff that the wise men gave to Jesus. Two of the things.
大约10分钟后，我完全好了。哇。所以我把这件事写进我的日记里了。我查了一下，在亚马逊上找到了同款。里面有这些成分。这就是我们把整件事变成精油推销的地方。顺便说一句，我们由简赞助，由简的精油和蜡烛出售。所以这里面有这些东西：薰衣草、薄荷、洋甘菊、一种叫依兰依兰的桦木。然后还有乳香和没药。那是智者送给耶稣的东西。其中两样东西。非常昂贵的东西。是的。高级。谁能想到呢？我甚至，我的意思是，我知道乳香和没药是真实的，但我不知道它们真的是实物。我的意思是，我以为它们只是一首圣诞歌曲的一部分。不是真的。但它们到底是什么？我想它们就是你晕船时抹在耳朵后面的东西。听起来他们就像把厨房洗手池里能倒的都倒进去了。
Very expensive stuff. Yeah. Fancy. Who knew? I didn't even, I mean, I know frankincense and myrrh are real, but I didn't know they were real. I mean, I thought they were part of a Christmas song. That's not real. But like, what are they? I guess they are what you rub behind your ears when you're seasick. It sounds like they just threw everything in the kitchen sink into this. Yeah. The Yolang Yolang, I don't know. Yolang Yolang. Yolang Yolang. All right. So in the script, there was a scene, Greg, that as the boat is pulling away, Toby's car suddenly drives up and he, and Michael yells at him from the ship, oh, come on. What's up? He's like, I'm sorry. There was an accident or there was traffic.
对。依兰依兰，我不知道。依兰依兰。依兰依兰。好吧。所以在剧本里，有一场戏，格雷格，当船正要驶离时，托比的车突然开过来，他，迈克尔在船上冲他大喊，哦，得了吧。怎么回事？他就像是，我很抱歉。出了点事故，或者有交通堵塞。然后迈克尔说，我们不会回去的。我们不会为了他回去的。别管他了。然后保罗（Paul）作为托比转头看着镜头，还抛了个媚眼。那是个大大的微笑。Yeah,就像他是故意的一样. 但你可以在删减片段里找到这个。我们拍了。是的。我们拍了。而且非常搞笑。这就是为什么托比没有上船，对于任何想知道的人来说。也许我们应该拿——
And then Michael says, we're not going back. We're not going back from him. Just leave him. And then Paul turns to camera as Toby and he kind of gives a little wink. That's a big smile. Yeah, like he did on purpose. But you can find that in the deleted scenes. We shot it. Yes. We shot it. And it was very nice. And that is why Toby is not on the boat for anyone who was wondering. Maybe we should take- There's a lot of excuses for why Toby wouldn't be on things so that he could help out as a writer and producer. Toby and BJ and Mindy, like they sat in the, you know, Mindy was in the annex, like things like that. I thought I was so clever in season one making them actors so that they would have this experience of being actors. And then
对于托比为什么不参加各种活动，有很多借口，这样他就可以作为编剧和制片人去帮忙。托比、B.J.和明迪，他们坐在，你知道的，明迪在副楼里，诸如此类的事情。我在第一季时还觉得自己太聪明了，让他们当演员，这样他们就能体验当演员的感觉。然后到了第二季的某个时候，我环顾四周，50%的编剧都不见了，因为他们在片场拍戏。我就想，哦，我都干了些什么？好吧。在7分55秒。罗布·里格尔笑场了。他彻底笑场了。什么？我们聊过这个。它直接留在了镜头里。所以罗布饰演的杰克船长正在讲解船上的安全设施。而迈克尔真的很想抢过这段发言自己来讲。但他做不到。所以他开始像空乘人员一样，指向出口。是的。
at some point in season two, I'm looking around and 50% of the writers are gone because they're on set. I'm like, oh, what have I done? Okay. At seven minutes, 55 seconds. Rob Riggle breaks. He totally breaks. What? We talked about it. It just, it stayed in the shot. So Rob is Captain Jack is going over the safety features of the boat. And Michael really wants to hijack this speech and give it. And he can't. So he just starts doing like the flight attendant, like pointing to the exits. Yeah. And Rob just breaks. He just starts laughing, but he just keeps going. And then Rain is Dwight laughs. And so it just sort of like, but it stays in. Oh, that's amazing. But Rob was like, yeah, I just, I just laughed. And I, but I just kept talking through
然后罗布就笑场了。他开始笑，但他一直坚持说下去。然后雷恩饰演的德怀特也笑了。所以这就像是，但它被保留下来了。哦，太棒了。但罗布当时的状态是，是的，我只是，我笑了。但我一直带着笑意把话说完。当史蒂夫在跳舞的时候。是的。我记得当时试图建立大家的反应，因为每个人都应该表现得无动于衷，而且（保持）严肃的面孔。这几乎是不可能的，因为每个人都在笑场，这让他不得不一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地跳那个舞。跳了那么久。那是，我记得，我记得当我们重看这一段时，我只写了，哦天哪，迈克尔的舞，因为他跳了太久了。我在日记里写道，我们大约在凌晨两点开始拍摄那场戏。真的很晚。来自塔拉·莱奇克（Tara Leitchke）的粉丝提问。史蒂夫的舞蹈是编排好的吗？
my laugh. When Steve is doing his dancing. Yes. That I remember like trying to build the reactions because everybody's supposed to be like unimpressed and just, you know, straight faced. And it was almost impossible because everybody was breaking and made him do that over and over and over again. For so long. That's, I remember, I was, I remember when we rewatched it, I just wrote, oh my gosh, Michael's dance because he danced for so long. In my journal, I said that we started taping that around two AM. Like it was really late. Yeah. A fan question from Tara Leitchke. Was Steve's dance choreographed? I don't think so. I really think he improvised that. I don't remember it being in the script. I think he just kind of went for it. I have the script at home for this
我不觉得。我真的觉得他是即兴发挥的。我不记得剧本里有这个。我觉得他只是豁出去了。我家有这一集的剧本，我读过，剧本里没有任何关于迈克尔舞蹈的指令。它只写着：镜头切到迈克尔在跳一段奇怪的舞蹈。是的。就这样。也就只有这些。另一个关于舞蹈的粉丝提问。史蒂夫·德雷瑟（Steve Dresser）问，为了拍出史蒂夫的完整舞姿，那段精彩的舞蹈拍了多少条？我猜大概六条吧，我觉得。是的。你觉得呢？你还记得吗？这听起来差不多。我不记得他是从什么时候开始拍打自己的腿的。对，那太惊人了。那是很早还是后来。还有虫子舞。我的意思是，它们是不同的。我觉得有不同版本的舞蹈，然后我们挑选了精彩片段。是的。
episode and I read it and there is no direction for Michael's dance in the script. It just says, pan over to see Michael doing a weird dance. Yeah. That's it. That's as much as there was. Another fan question about the dance. Steve Dresser says, how many takes of that superb dance did it take to get Steve's full moves? I'm going to say about six, I think. Yeah. What do you think? What do you remember? That seems about right. I can't remember when he started slapping his legs. Yeah, that was amazing. If that was early on or later. And the worm. I mean, they were different. I feel like there were different versions of the dance and then we kind of made the highlight reel. Yes. On the deleted scenes, you can see even more of the dancing
在删减片段里，如果你想看的话，你可以看到更多的舞蹈。我记得当肯（Ken）终于说，好吧，卡。史蒂夫正趴在地上跳虫子舞。那是最后一条。是的。然后他站起来，所有人为他鼓掌。你们过去给了他一个拥抱，因为他真的是全力以赴了。太累人了。是的，他完全做到了。太棒了。这是一个粉丝提问。迈克尔跳舞的时候有音乐在放，还是后来加进去的？我的记忆是后来加进去的。我的意思是，我觉得我们经常做的是，我们会伴着音乐拍一条，然后某人戴着一个微型入耳式耳机，他们会说，你想用耳机听着跳吗？为了做出一个可以播放音轨的微小隐形设备，花了很多心血。然后演员会说，不，我不需要。
if you want to. I remember when Ken finally was like, okay, cut. Steve was on the ground doing the worm. That was the last one. Yeah. And he got up and everyone applauded for him. And you guys came over and gave him a hug because he had really gone for it. I was exhausting. Yeah, he completely did. That was amazing. Here's a fan question. Was their music playing when Michael danced or was it added later? My memory is that it was added later. I mean, I feel like what we often did was we would do one take with the music and then somebody would have a little earwig and they would say, do you want to do it with an earwig? And a lot of effort had gone into making a tiny invisible thing that could play the soundtrack. And then the actor would go,
然后仅凭记忆拍接下来五条。我觉得当时大概就是这么回事。我确实记得一些关于酒水游轮上乐队的趣事。是的，我们有很多关于乐队的问题。是的，正好。因为我的朋友小鲍勃·迪尔（Bob Deal, Jr.），正如你在卡片上指出的那样，他创作了我们的主题曲，他就在乐队里，乐队里四个成员中有三个就是演奏我们主题曲的人，哈尔·克雷根（Hal Craigon）和迪伦也是。迪伦·奥布莱恩（Dylan O'Brien），他是洛杉矶的一个大词曲创作者。这些人是我的朋友，或者说鲍勃是。办公室的主题曲是由杰·弗格森（Jay Ferguson）写的，但他发过一个合成器版本的过来，很棒。这显然是一首好歌。很喜欢。但它听起来，没有你想要的能量。所以鲍勃把他的一群朋友组成了这样一支摇滚乐队。
no, I don't need it. And then do the next five takes just for memory. That's how I feel like it probably went down. I do remember some fun facts about the band on Boo's Cruise. Yes, we had a lot of questions about the band. Yes, exactly. Because my friend Bob Deal, Jr., as you were pointing out on your card, who did our theme song was in the band and three out of the four band people were the guys who played our theme song, Hal Craigon and Dylan also. Dylan O'Brien, who's a big songwriter in LA. And these guys were friends of mine or Bob was. And the theme song for the office was written by Jay Ferguson, but he sent over a version of it on Synthesizer, which was great. It was obviously a great song. Loved it. But it didn't sound, didn't have the energy that
我们去录音室用所有真实的乐器把主题曲录了下来。是的。太酷了。我以前不知道。是的。太酷了。然后他成了，然后他把他的乐队命名为“斯克兰顿人”（The Scrantons）。是的。然后他跟我们一起去了斯克兰顿，经常在我们的派对上演奏。他还在，我有一位粉丝写信说，他也出现在菲尔斯的婚礼上，和凯文一起在“斯克兰顿交响乐团”（Scrantonicity）里。我也有个粉丝。凡妮莎·麦克劳德（Vanessa McLoad）说她注意到至少有一个乐队成员后来出现在菲尔斯婚礼上的“斯克兰顿交响乐团”里。对，就是鲍勃。鲍勃还为《混乱之子》（Sons of Anarchy）和《玛雅帮》（Mayans）创作过音乐。所以他相当有才华。
you'd want. And so Bob had this kind of rock and band that he put together of his friends. And we went and recorded the theme song with all live instruments in a session. Yeah. That is so cool. I did not know that. Yeah. That is so cool. And then he became, then he called his band The Scrantons. Yeah. And then he came to Scranton with us and would play at our parties often. And he was in the, I had a fan write in and say that he's also in Phyllis's wedding with Kevin in Scrantonicity. I had a fan as well. Vanessa McLoad said that she noticed that at least one of the band members shows up later in Scrantonicity at Phyllis's wedding. Yeah, it's Bob. Bob also did music, the music for Sons of Anarchy and the Mayans. So he's quite talented.
他太有才华了。我在11分14秒处发现。如果你认识这三个人，这真的很疯狂。菲尔斯、凯文和安吉拉在一起跳舞。哦。什么？我跟你说。有一个镜头是菲尔斯在某个时刻和克里德跳舞吗？是的。是的。快到结尾时有。他们在一起跳舞。但我们跳的是那种尴尬的舞，就像，我几乎觉得像在八年级，一群女孩在一起跳舞，除了那里面有我、菲尔斯和凯文。我们只是在做那种小幅度的摇晃。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，我不知道你是否还记得，格雷格，有一个贯穿全剧的笑话。我在剧本里读到过，然后我回去在删减片段里看到了。这一集里有一个贯穿始终的笑话：奥斯卡是个酒品极差的酒鬼。
He's so talented. I have at 11 minutes 14 seconds. This is really crazy if you know these three people. Phyllis, Kevin and Angela are dancing together. Oh. What? I'm telling you. Is there a shot of Phyllis dancing with Creed at one point? Yes. Yes. Towards the end there is. They're dancing together. But we're doing that, that awkward dance where like, I almost feel like an eighth grade where like a group of girls dance together except it's me Phyllis and Kevin. We're just kind of doing like a little sway like that. It's just very funny to me. Well, I don't know if you remember Greg, but there was a runner. I read it in the script and then I went back and I saw it in the deleted scenes. There was this whole runner through this episode that Oscar is a really mean drunk.
是的。很高兴我们把它剪掉了。是的。我不喜欢那样。我也读过剧本，当时我想，哦，很高兴我们没用这个。在那里他只是，他喝醉了，然后到处走，侮辱你们所有人。所以这可能就是为什么奥斯卡没有和你们一起跳舞。而且后来。他把自己孤立了。是的，后来。只有我和凯文在卡座里。是的。可能就是这个原因。因为奥斯卡跑去谈论你们了。我把这事给忘了。好吧，我想回到吉姆、凯蒂、帕姆和罗伊围坐在桌子旁的那个场景。太棒了。凯蒂评论说，哦，我们坐在酷桌这里。然后他们都聊起自己高中时是什么样的人，除了吉姆。我们没听到关于吉姆的事，但我们发现凯蒂曾是个拉拉队长，
Yes. I'm glad we cut that. Yeah. I didn't like that. I read the script too and I was like, oh, glad we didn't use this. Where he's just, he's getting drunk and then he's going around and he's insulting all of you. So that is probably why Oscar is not dancing with you guys. And also later. He's isolated himself. Yeah, later. It's just Kevin and I in the booth. Yeah. That's probably why. Because Oscar's off like talking about you. I forgot about that. Well, I want to go back to the scene with Jim, Katie, Pam and Roy sitting around the table. Great. Katie makes a comment where she says, oh, we're at the cool table. And then they all talk about what they were like in high school, except Jim. We don't hear about Jim, but we find out that Katie was a cheerleader
而帕姆是个文青艺术范儿。谢谢你，罗伊。罗伊以前搞体育，然后艾米来了段她的啦啦队助威。艾米饰演的凯蒂来了一段精彩的啦啦队助威，那不在剧本里。我们在片场发现艾米·亚当斯曾是一名拉拉队长，她会好几套助威动作，你让她为我们现场表演一小段助威动作，好让我们做出反应。艾米和我一起做了几个助威动作。我们当时都累得脑子转不动了，伙计们。当时大概凌晨三点，你知道的。所以你还记得吗？因为我记得当我们拍那场戏时，艾米开始做拉拉队的动作，我们拍了好几条，然后肯想继续拍别的，但有什么事一直在烦扰着我，我不想就这么放过那个场景。我意识到这种平衡，她有点打破了平衡，因为艾米·亚当斯显然是个非常有魅力、你知道的、漂亮的演员，她做了那个非常有趣、可爱的拉拉队表演。然后我们就要继续拍别的了。
and that Pam was artsy fartsy. Thanks, Roy. And that Roy played sports and then Amy does her little cheer. Amy as Katie does her awesome cheer and that was not in the script. We found out on the set that Amy Adams was a cheerleader and she knew a bunch of cheers and she did, you had her do little cheers for us to react to. Amy and I did a few cheers together. We were all really punchy, you guys. It was like three in the morning, you know. So do you remember, because I remember when we were doing that scene and Amy started to do the cheerleader stuff, we did a couple of takes of it and then Ken wanted to move on and something was bothering me and I didn't want to move on from that scene. And I realized that the balance, she kind of shifted
而我意识到帕姆基本上没有在同一个层面上参与进来。她有点否认自己当过啦啦队长的经历，但她没有做她自己具有吸引力的事。我们回过头去，在9分0分9秒，我走到你面前对我说，你得把这个情绪往上提一个档次，做点什么。你还记得吗？对。然后你有点嘲弄她的啦啦队动作，你做了那个。而我就想，对，因为那不在剧本里。那不是，那是当时即兴加入的。那就是，呃，我在那儿有点调戏吉姆。我在桌子旁有了一个私密的时刻。我觉得这太大胆了，罗伊就坐在你旁边。当我再次看这一段时，我想，等一下，罗伊就在她旁边，她居然还敢调戏吉姆，顺便还嘲笑了凯蒂。是的。我觉得帕姆当时正经历着内心独白。好吧，我觉得这是一个很重要的连接点，格雷格，因为这肯定有助于给吉姆勇气去做他打算做的事，也就是向帕姆表露他的心意。
the balance because Amy Adams is obviously very charismatic, you know, beautiful actress and she did that really fun, cute cheerleader thing. And then we were going to move on. And I realized like Pam is just basically not participating on the same level here. She's kind of denying the cheerleader thing, but she isn't doing her own charismatic thing. And we went back and at 9 0 9, I went back to you and I said, you got to kick this up a notch, do something. Do you remember that? Yeah. And then you kind of mocked her cheerleader thing and you did that. And I was like, yeah, because that was not in the script. That wasn't that was added in the moment. And that's, uh, yeah, I kind of, I kind of flirt with Jim there. I have a private moment at the table. I thought that was like
是的。我觉得如果没有他们俩因另一半的行为如此荒唐而产生共鸣的那一小段时刻，你就需要看到他们建立起那种紧密的联系。是的。这样吉姆觉得“这可能是我的时刻”就不会显得那么突兀了。好吧，还有，帕姆在船顶上确实给了他们一个机会。她确实给了。是的。对我来说，关于吉姆的那一部分是：她订婚了，而他想做一个好人，你知道的，尊重她订婚的事实。但是他同时也觉得，所有这些迹象都在表明可能有什么情况，而他却没有采取行动。看着这一幕真的非常令人沮丧。是的。看着太揪心了，但也觉得非常真实，因为你当时就会那样。你不会，你想把一切都说出来，却又说不出口。好吧，我记得，对我和我来说，那可能是写进剧本里的最私人、最赤裸的事情之一，因为这感觉不怎么像是一个高尚的、成功的吉姆、社交达人的时刻。这感觉真的很像人们会因此讨厌他、不尊重他之类的。
so bold with Roy sitting next to you. Like when I watched it again, I was like, wait, she's flirting with Jim with Roy next to her and also kind of making fun of Katie. Yeah. I was like, Pam's having a moment. Well, I think it was an important connection there, Greg, because it is certainly going to help give Jim the courage to do what he's going to attempt to do, which is tell Pam his feelings. Yeah. I think without that little moment of them bonding over how ridiculous their significant others are being, it's like you need to see them as that bonded couple. Yeah. So it doesn't come so out of the blue that Jim would think this could be my moment. Well, also, Pam really gives them an opening on the top of the boat there. She does. Yeah.
所以我当时觉得把它摆在明面上是有风险的。我不知道。在剪辑时要把这一段保留这么长时间也很难。我的意思是，我们试图做到和你们在现场拍的那场戏保持同样的长度。当时有很多想要把它剪短的冲动。让人们一直不说话，这时间未免太长了。是的。我们来聊聊这一段。太美了。太美了。帕姆和吉姆在船的甲板上，帕姆确实给了他一个机会。她说，有时我就是搞不懂罗伊。这是我们第一次看到她向吉姆抱怨罗伊，贬低她的感情。真的，这是她第一次把这种情绪用言语表达出来。我不知道，我几乎可以肯定。然后是27秒的沉默。一位粉丝写信来，安东尼·斯尼德（Anthony Snead）说，那段尴尬沉默背后的动机是什么？在这27秒里发生了很多事。
Yeah. That to me, the Jim thing of it was she's engaged and he wants to be a good person and, you know, respect the fact that she's engaged. And, but he's also like, there's all these clues coming in that there could be something and he doesn't go for it. And it's very frustrating to watch. It is. It's so painful to watch, but also feels so honest because that's how you would be. You wouldn't, you'd want to say everything and you wouldn't be able to. Well, I remember, to me, that was probably one of the most personal and sort of raw things that I would have put into a script because it did not feel like a very like noble Jim successful social, social guy moment. It felt really like people are going to hate him for this or disrespect him or whatever. So I kind
仅仅因为人们没有说话并不意味着什么都没发生。我想你看着他的脸，你知道的，你能看出他在尝试各种不同的事情，在思考，被（内心）催促着前进，又被阻拦，你知道的，然后我也觉得在你的脸上，有一种他对什么都不做感到失望的情绪，还有当你说“好吧，我好冷”时那种挽回面子的感觉。其实天冷倒挺好的。而且我们确实是在港口外面拍的，因为我觉得如果没有那样，你的鼻子就不会红了。对，我是真的很冷。对，你是很冷。对，我信了。现在，格雷格，剧本里并没有写会有一个大段的停顿。上面没有写“这里有一个漫长的大停顿”。是的。上面只写了他们看着对方，然后帕姆终于开口了。是的。
of felt it was risky to put it out there. I don't know. It was very hard also in the edit to keep it that long. I mean, we tried to make the same length that you guys really did in the scene. And there was a lot of urge to like trim that up. That's an awful long time to have people not talk. Yes. Let's talk about that. It's so beautiful. It's so beautiful. Pam and Jim are on the deck of that boat and Pam does give him an opening. She says, sometimes I just don't get Roy. And this is the first time we've seen her complain about Roy to Jim, to disparage her relationship. Really, it's the first time she's verbalized it. I don't, I'm pretty sure. And then it is 27 seconds of silence. And a fan wrote in Anthony Snead said, what was the motivation behind that awkward
但我记得在拍摄当天，你真的鼓励我们放慢节奏，不要害怕只是看着对方。好吧，我的意思是，那是，我觉得正是这一点让这部剧如此特别，并且与电视上的其他节目截然不同，你知道的，行为的瞬间比笑话、铺垫、包袱和台词等东西要重要得多。所以，而且我觉得这来自于对纪录片优点的欣赏。纪录片全都是关于在人们所做的事情中寻找真实并倾听进去。无论他们认为自己在做什么，或者他们说自己在做什么，他们的行动向你展示了他们在做什么？这是一个很好的浪漫例子，你知道的，一切都在字里行间，一切都在脸上，而不在剧本里。说得太妙了。伙计们，我们该聊聊这场戏期间还发生了什么吗？
silence? There's a lot going on in those 27 seconds. Just because people aren't talking doesn't mean nothing's going on. And I think that you look at his face and, you know, you can see him trying out different things and thinking and being, you know, urged to go forward and blocked and, you know, and, and then I think also on your face, there's all this kind of like disappointment that he's not going to do anything and face saving when you're like, well, I'm cold and kind of, it was kind of good that it was cold actually. And we really did shoot it out in the harbor because I think you wouldn't have been able to, like your nose was red. Yeah, I was cold. Yeah, you were cold. Yeah, I believed it. Now, Greg, it wasn't in the script
你是说当半个剧组在海上迷路的时候吗？是的。好吧，事情是这样的。当我们开始拍这场戏时，我想我们知道这会花一些时间。所以他们告诉其他演员可以提前收工离开，但离开这艘船的唯一方法——因为我们不打算把船开回去停靠。不，有一些小艇会开过来，你坐上小艇，它会把你带到岸边。没错。好吧，事情并没有按计划进行。没有，并没有。我记得收到了一个惊慌失措的对讲机呼叫。载着菲尔斯的船不见了。看我的卡片。你当时也在那艘船上。我也被困在船上了。还有布赖恩，对吧？还有雷恩。我把它写进我的日记里了。是的。太疯狂了。好吧，不知为什么，我满脑子都在想那是菲尔斯。我们弄丢了菲尔斯。她看起来是这群人里最脆弱的一个。心地善良的菲尔斯。
that there would be a big pause. It didn't say there's a long, big pause. Yeah. It just says that they look at each other and then finally Pam says. Yeah. But I remember on the day, you really encouraging us to take our time and don't be afraid to just look at each other. Well, I mean, that was part of, I think what made the show so special was that, and so different from what was on TV, you know, was that moments of behavior were really important more so than jokes and setups and punchlines and lines and stuff. And so, and I think that came out of appreciating what's good about a documentary. And documentaries just are all about finding the truth in what people are doing and leaning in. And no matter what they think they're doing or what
所以我写了关于她的事。我等不及想听她怎么说了。好吧，她说她的第一个记忆，她说大约是凌晨两点半，她正在等待离开这艘船。她的第一个记忆是看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔坐在一艘极小的小艇上，抓着某种杆子，没有穿救生衣，消失在夜色中。她记得当时想，如果NBC知道他们的明星没有穿救生衣，而且正被拉回港口，他们会生气的。然后她上了船，她以为那是奥斯卡、布赖恩和服装部门的某个人。我在前一天把它写下来了。是你。是的。哦，她说，我不确定安吉拉当时在不在。然后她讲了，刚开船时一切都很好。我们正在享受海洋的气味、远处的灯光。然后突然之间，什么都没有了，发动机熄火了。所以你当时确实在那儿。所以这就是我在拍完那场戏的第二天写的内容。好吧。我写道，我们在拍这个的时候发生的最酷的事情之一
they say they're doing, what are they, what are their actions show you that they're doing? And this was like a good romantic example of, you know, it all being in between the lines and it all being on the faces and not in the script. That is so smartly said. You guys, should we talk about what else was going on during this scene? Do you mean when half of the cast got lost at sea? Yes. All right, so here's the deal. When we started this scene, I think we knew it was going to take a while. And so they told the other cast members that they could leave for the day, but the only way to get off the boat because we weren't going to take the boat back and dock it. No, there were these little dinghies that would pull up and you would get in the little boat and
他们嘴上说在做什么，实际上他们的行动又向你展示了他们在做什么？这就像是一个很好的浪漫例子，你知道的，这一切都在字里行间，都在演员的表情上，而不在剧本里。这话真是太聪明了。大家伙儿，我们要不要聊聊这场戏期间还发生了什么？你是说当一半的演员在海上迷路的时候吗？是的。好吧，事情是这样的。当我们开始拍这场戏时，我想我们都知道这会花上一段时间。所以他们告诉其他演员今天可以收工了，但是离开船的唯一方式——因为我们不会把船开回去靠岸——不，当时有那种小艇会开过来，你坐进小艇里
it would take you to shore. Exactly. Well, that did not go as planned. No, it didn't. I remember getting this panicky radio thing. The boat with Phyllis on it is gone. Look at my card. You were on the boat too. I was stranded on the boat. And Brian too, right? And rain. And I wrote about it in my journal. Yeah. It was crazy. Well, for some reason it fixated on me that it was Phyllis. The Phyllis was that we had lost Phyllis. She seems like the most vulnerable of the group. Right kind, Phyllis. Yeah. So I wrote her about. I can't wait to hear what she says. Well, she says the first memory, she says it was about 2.30 in the morning and she was waiting to leave the ship. And her first memory was seeing Steve Carell on a tiny little boat holding onto some kind of a pole with
它会把你送到岸边。没错。嗯，事情并没有按计划进行。确实没有。我记得收到过一个惊慌失措的对讲机消息。载着菲利斯的船不见了。看我的卡片。你当时也在船上。我被困在船上了。还有布莱恩对吧？还有雷恩。我在日记里写过这事。是的。太疯狂了。好吧，不知为什么我脑子里认定是菲利斯。我们弄丢了菲利斯。她似乎是这群人中最脆弱的一个。心地善良的菲利斯。是的。所以我写了关于她的事。我等不及想听她说说这事了。嗯，她说最初的记忆是，大约凌晨两点半，她正等着离开大船。她的第一个记忆是看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔坐在一艘极小的船上，抓着某种杆子，
no lifejacket disappearing into the night. And she remembers thinking that if NBC knew that their star didn't have a lifejacket and was being pulled off back to the harbor, they would be upset. And then she got on the boat and she thought it was Oscar, Brian, and somebody from the wardrobe department. I wrote about it the day before. It was you. Yeah. Oh, she says, I'm not sure if Angela was there or not. And then she talks, everything was fine pulling away. We were enjoying the smell of the ocean, the lights and the distance. And then all of a sudden, nothing, the engine died. So you were there. So this is what I wrote the day after we filmed the scene. All right. I wrote, one of the coolest things that happened to me while we shot this
没有穿救生衣，消失在夜色中。她记得当时想，如果NBC知道他们的明星没有穿救生衣被拉回港口，他们一定会生气的。然后她上了船，她以为那是奥斯卡、布莱恩以及服装部门的某个人。我在前一天写过这事。就是你。是的。哦，她说，她不确定安吉拉当时在不在。然后她说到，一开始一切正常，我们驶离大船。我们享受着大海的气味、远处的灯光。然后突然之间，什么都没了，发动机熄火了。所以你当时确实在那儿。所以这就是我在拍摄这场戏的第二天写的内容。好吧。我写道，我在拍摄期间经历的最酷的事情之一是
episode happened the last night. Or I guess I should say the morning of. Rain, Phyllis, and Brian and I were all wrapped at 5.30 a.m. We were on the main boat, but they said they had more shooting to do. So we could stay on the big boat and like sleep in a booth. Yeah. Or they said they had these little rubber boats that would pull up next to the big boat that we could get on and they would take us to shore. So we said, okay, we'll do that. They said it's about a 15 minute boat ride on the little rubber dingy. So we decided to do it. It was really tricky getting on the rubber boat. Yeah. We just had to climb out a ladder off the side of the boat. And these guys got very unstable. Phyllis said that at one point she had to switch boats. She was terrified of
事情发生在昨天晚上。或者我想我应该说是清晨。雨、菲利斯、布莱恩和我在早上5点半左右收工。我们在主船上，但他们说还有镜头要拍。所以我们可以呆在大船上，比如在船舱里睡觉。是的。或者他们说有那种小橡皮艇，会开到大船旁边，我们可以坐上去，它们会把我们带到岸边。所以我们说，好吧，我们就这么办。他们说坐小橡皮艇去岸大概要15分钟。所以我们决定这么做。上橡皮艇真的很难。是的。我们只需要从船侧面的梯子爬下去。这些家伙变得很不稳定。菲利斯说，有一次她不得不换船。她吓坏了
falling in. Yes. And I said, okay, the little rubber boat, picture the kind of like rubber boat that the Navy SEALs do the backflips off of with the little like me like outboat. That's what this looked like. So we're lowered down into it. And it was me, Rain, Jen, one of our wardrobe gals Phyllis and Brian. It was tiny and really bouncy. We took off. It was dark out and the ocean looked like black glass. It was very peaceful. Oh, sorry. About five minutes into our ride, our engine made a weird whirring sound and stopped working. And then we heard the boat driver radio and say, the engine's dead. You need to come get us. Brian started laughing and said, you've got to be kidding me. Then we just floated in the darkness, which felt like for a
会掉下去。是的。我说，好吧，小橡皮艇，想象一下那种海豹突击队在后面做后空翻的橡皮艇，带着那种小型舷外发动机。这就是这个样子的。所以我们被放了下去。当时有我、雷恩、詹、我们的一个服装化妆师菲利斯和布莱恩。它很小，而且真的很颠簸。我们出发了。天很黑，海洋看起来像黑色的玻璃。非常平静。哦，对不起。大约在我们航行五分钟后，我们的发动机发出奇怪的嗡嗡声，然后停止工作了。然后我们听到船员通过无线电呼叫说，发动机死机了。你们得来接我们。布莱恩开始大笑并说，你一定在开玩笑。然后我们就漂浮在黑暗中，感觉就像
while. It was quiet and peaceful. It turned into the Titanic. I know. I know. And then we with another rubber boat pulled up and then we had to just straddle from one rubber boat, with just two guys kind of holding it together into the other one. This was very tricky. We slowly made our way past the Queen Mary, picture an old cruise ship that looks like the Titanic. And there was a huge plume of fire coming from a refinery behind it. Rain said to me, this is so surreal. And that's exactly what it was. You know, the wheels really came off when we went on locations. We talk about this a little bit. I mean, you know, this is for season nine, but you know, death bus almost killed us all. Yes. Work bus. Work bus. I should say. We've
一段时间。四周安静而平和。这变成了《泰坦尼克号》。我知道。我知道。然后我们看到另一艘橡皮艇靠过来，然后我们不得不从一艘橡皮艇跨到另一艘橡皮艇上，只有两个家伙勉强把它固定在一起。这真的很棘手。我们慢慢地从玛丽女王号旁边驶过，想象一艘看起来像《泰坦尼克号》的老式游轮。后面的一家炼油厂腾起了一团巨大的火焰。雷恩对我说，这太超现实了。事实确实如此。你知道，当我们外景拍摄时，事情真的失控了。我们稍微聊过这个。我是说，你知道，这是为了第九季，但是你知道，死亡巴士差点害死我们所有人。是的。工作巴士。工作巴士。我应该这么说。我们
called it death bus for so long. The cast calls it death bus. All right, well, we'll take a break and we'll be back. All right, so we're back from break. I have a question for you, Greg. Yeah. I've been waiting to ask you this. I know we're sort of jumping around with time codes, but at 11 minutes, 34 seconds, there's this beautiful shot that goes outside of the boat and goes around the boat. You passed white, right? Like steering and it goes around the boat. How did we do that? That is Kent Zabornak. So Kent was our line producer and he was also in the DGA and, you know, he managed to launch us on the budget that we had, which was tiny, you know, into Long Beach Harbor on a boat for days and get hotel rooms for everybody. And he realized that we really needed
叫它死亡巴士已经很久了。演员们都叫它死亡巴士。好吧，我们休息一下，马上回来。好的，我们休息回来了。格雷格，我有个问题要问你。是的。我一直等着问你这个。我知道我们在时间码上有点跳跃，但是在11分34秒的时候，有一个美丽的镜头，拍到了船的外侧，绕着船转。你经过了白色，对吧？就像掌舵一样，它绕着船转。我们是怎么做到的？那是肯特·扎博纳克。肯特是我们的制片主任，他也是DGA成员，你知道，他设法在我们那点微薄的预算下，让我们在长滩港的一艘船上拍了好几天，并为每个人订了酒店房间。他意识到我们真的需要
that a shot like that. And he shot that himself with his own equipment, you know, while we were shooting the rest of it, because he just had an instinct that there was no way the production could get that and stop everything. And, you know, so that was kind of a gorilla move and super valuable. And Kent was, you know, fantastic at doing those kind of things like he was always stitching together amazing stuff on our little budget. That is so cool. I did not know that. Did you? No. When I saw it, I was like, wait, I know Randall and Matt were inside with us. Yeah, who did that, right? Our camera guys. I was like, how did that happen? And then I was like, is that a plane? Like, it's in the air. Like how that, I mean, is it a drone? Like, what is it?
那样的镜头。他用自己的设备亲自拍了那个镜头，你知道，在我们拍其余部分的时候，因为他有一种直觉，制作组绝对没办法拿到那个镜头然后停下所有事情。所以，你知道，那有点像游击队的做法，而且超级有价值。肯特，你知道的，做这种事情非常在行，就像他总是在我们的小预算下把一些了不起的东西拼凑在一起。太酷了。我不知道那个。你知道吗？不。当我看到它的时候，我在想，等等，我知道兰德尔和马特和我们在一起。是的，那是谁做的，对吧？我们的摄像师。我想，那是怎么发生的？然后我在想，那是一架飞机吗？就像，它在空中。就像那样，我是说，那是无人机吗？就像，那是什么？
He's on one of those dinghies. He's on one of those zodiac dinghies. He's on a dinghie. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. All right. Wow. This is another question about a camera movement. So, you know, after they're at the bar and they're all talking about who they would save, Jim gets up his courage and he's going to walk over to Pam and he says, I would save the receptionist. I think I need to make that clear. Well, right before that, Greg Phelps noticed at 14 minutes, 37 seconds, there's a continuous shot of Jim looking down the length of the boat to Pam as he thinks about who he would save. The camera then zooms in on Pam at the exact moment she has a really cute laughing smile. How did you time that out so perfectly? He wants to know, Jenna, were you given a cue when
他在其中一艘橡皮艇上。他在那些佐地克橡皮艇之一上。他在一艘橡皮艇上。是的。好的。是的。好吧。哇。这是关于摄像机移动的另一个问题。所以，你知道，在他们去酒吧之后，他们都在谈论他们会救谁，吉姆鼓起勇气，他要走向帕姆，他说，我会救前台。我想我需要把这一点说清楚。好吧，就在那之前，格雷格·菲尔普斯注意到在14分37秒时，有一个连续镜头，吉姆顺着船长长的通道看着帕姆，当他思考他会救谁时。镜头随后拉近到帕姆身上，就在她露出一个非常可爱的微笑的那一刻。你们是怎么把时间卡得这么完美的？他想知道，珍娜，当
the camera was about to zoom in on you? But we used to do that stuff all the time. That was, go ahead. People, I think, have the wrong idea about how we did the show in a way because, like, most filmmaking is super intentional. And you would say to the camera operator, okay, at this signal, you need to zoom in and then you'd try and get the actor to do it at exactly the right time. And our show was more like the theory of natural selection kind of like there would be a situation. And I would give notes or the directors would give notes to the camera operators that were not about what they did specifically, but more about their intentions. So we would say, okay, you're really interested in what he sees down at the end of the hall. So just go find it.
镜头要拉近到你身上时，有人给你暗号了吗？但我们以前经常那样做。那是，请说。人们，我认为，对我们拍摄这部剧的方式有一种错误的看法，因为，就像，大多数电影制作都是超级有意的。你会对摄像师说，好吧，在这个信号下，你需要拉近镜头，然后你会试图让演员在完全正确的时间做出反应。而我们的节目更像是自然选择理论，某种程度上，会有那样的情况。我会给出笔记，或者导演会给摄像师笔记，这些笔记不是关于他们具体做什么，而是更多关于他们的意图。所以我们会说，好吧，你真的很想知道他在大厅尽头看到了什么。所以去找它。
And we had all these people who had come from reality shows who were used to finding the story on their own. And that turned out great, you know. And I can't really speak for Ken as the director. He directed it. And he might have known exactly what he was going for and kept doing it until he got it. But a lot of the times, there were just lots of happy accidents. And then you would tell the story through all the happy accidents. And you had enough, like, flexibility that you could have gone a bunch of different ways with it. I think our editors don't get enough credit. Well, first of all, I think our camera operators and don't get enough credit for all of those happy accidents. But then you would assemble those with the editors in the editing room to tell even more
我们有所有这些来自真人秀的人，他们习惯于自己寻找故事。事实证明这很棒，你知道的。我不能真的以导演的身份代表肯。他执导的。他可能确切地知道他追求的是什么，并一直这样做直到他得到它。但很多时候，只是有很多幸运的意外。然后你通过所有这些幸运的意外来讲述故事。你拥有足够的灵活性，可以用好几种不同的方式处理它。我认为我们的剪辑师没有得到足够的赞赏。好吧，首先，我认为我们的摄像师没有为所有这些幸运的意外得到足够的赞赏。但随后你会在剪辑室里和剪辑师一起把这些组合起来，讲述更多
of a story than what was in the script. Totally. The editors are amazing. We had fantastic editors. This one was Dean. Dave Rogers is, you know, I'm still working with work with them all the time. Brilliant. Claire Scanlon. Claire Scanlon. Also brilliant. And there was enormous amounts of leeway for the editors. And in post, because like a documentary, we shot way more stuff than we could ever possibly use. And so our rough cuts were always about 38 minutes long. But the show is only 21 minutes and six seconds or something like that. So tons of good material was discarded. And that was a large part of my job. I loved being on set. And I also loved being with the writers. But this whole other area of my job was sitting with the editors and their fun people,
比剧本里的还要多的故事。完全正确。剪辑师太棒了。我们有出色的剪辑师。这个是迪恩。戴夫·罗杰斯，你知道的，我一直在和他们合作。才华横溢。克莱尔·斯坎伦。克莱尔·斯坎伦。同样才华横溢。剪辑师有巨大的发挥空间。而在后期制作中，就像纪录片一样，我们拍摄的东西远多于我们可能用到的东西。所以我们的粗剪总是大约38分钟长。但节目只有21分6秒左右。所以大量的优质素材被丢弃了。这是我工作很大的一部分。我喜欢在片场。我也喜欢和编剧呆在一起。但我的工作的另一个完全不同的领域是和剪辑师坐在一起，他们也很有趣，
too, with great creative ideas. And you could tell so many different versions of the show by what you left in and what you took out. And there was always a thing where you'd go, everybody kind of agreed on the first six or eight minutes to get rid of. And probably we all agreed, having Oscar make snarky, mean comments is not great or whatever it is. But then you'd get to about 26 minutes and there was a lot of really good stuff. And I used to have all these regrets about things that were great that couldn't get in the show. And one of them for this, if you remember, was Creed sitting in with the band, finding out that he'd been in the grassroots. And that was like fantastic. And we had all this footage. And I found footage of him from, you know, late 60s,
也有着极具创意的想法。你可以通过你留下什么和拿走什么来讲述这个节目的许多不同版本。总会有这样的时刻，你会说，大家对剪掉前六到八分钟基本上都有共识。可能我们都同意，让奥斯卡发表刻薄、卑劣的评论是不好的，或者诸如此类。但随后你到了大约26分钟时，有很多非常好的东西。我曾经对那些没能进入节目的绝佳内容感到各种遗憾。其中一个，如果你还记得的话，就是克里德和乐队一起坐着，发现他曾经在草根乐队（The Grass Roots）待过。那简直太棒了。我们有所有的这些镜头。我找到了他来自，你知道的，60年代末的镜头，
and, you know, playing guitar with the grassroots on Playboy After Dark with Hugh Hefner, and like all these, all this great footage, which was going to be the B-roll under the, you know, under him talking about playing with all these greats in the late 60s. And that was in for a really long time. I think it's in the DVD extras. It is. It's in the deleted scenes. It's great. Michael, the guitar player is going to take a break. And then Michael tries to fill in for him. And he's horrible. And then Creed says, let me give it a shot. And then he just gets up there and rocks out. And it's so cool and satisfying. And then he has a talking head where he explains that he is himself, basically. He is Creed Breton, member of grassroots. And that he kind of fried his brain
而且，你知道的，在休·海夫纳的《花花公子深夜秀》（Playboy After Dark）上与草根乐队一起弹吉他，所有这些很棒的镜头，这些本来要作为B卷素材，放在他谈论在60年代末与所有这些伟人一起演奏的谈话头后面。这段内容保留了很长时间。我想它在DVD花絮里。确实如此。它在被删减的片段里。太棒了。迈克尔，吉他手要休息一下。然后迈克尔试图替补他。他糟透了。然后克里德说，让我试试。然后他就在那里摇滚起来。这太酷了，太令人满意了。然后他有一个谈话头镜头，解释说他基本上就是他自己。他是克里德·布拉顿，草根乐队的成员。他有点把自己的大脑用毒品给
with drug use. And now he can barely concentrate on his job. And then there's a talking head of Angela going, he wasn't that good for something like that. I've seen better. Oh, man. By the way, I would wear a shirt that says I'd save the receptionist. I think that is... We should have shirts that say I'd save the receptionist. I think that's so cute. I think Ken did a really good job with that, too, because that was, I believe, supposed to just be a talking head. And he... Yes, in the script, it's a talking head. Yeah. And he really rightly said, well, where exactly did he say this? Because he had the thought and then he walks over to Pam and then she gets interrupted by Roy setting a date. So he couldn't figure out where there was going to be a time to interview
搞坏了。现在他几乎无法专心工作。然后是一个安吉拉的谈话头镜头，说，他没那么好，诸如此类的。我见过更好的。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，我会穿一件写着“我会救前台”的衬衫。我觉得那是……我们应该做写着“我会救前台”的衬衫。我觉得这太可爱了。我认为肯在这方面也做得很好，因为那本应只是一段谈话头。他……是的，在剧本里，那是一段谈话头。是的。他非常正确地说，好吧，他到底是在哪里说的这话？因为他脑子里有了这个想法，然后他走向帕姆，接着她就被罗伊订婚期给打断了。所以他想不出什么时候会有时间去采访
him about this. And so it sort of invented this on-the-fly interview where he kind of just passed the cameraman and set it into camera. And then it was cool. Yeah, I really liked that. No, and you're with him. Like, Jim's got his courage. He's going to save the receptionist. He almost gets up to Pam. And that's when Roy stands up and says that he's setting a wedding date, June 10th. A fan question from Ed's arquisa said, was Pam genuinely happy when Roy proposed or was she just caught up in the moment? Well, I looked at the script. The script said, Pam looks happy. So I played it that Pam was genuinely kind of overcome with this moment. You know, she's been trying to get Roy's attention. I think she wants him to treat her like this so badly. And so...
他关于这件事的内容。所以它有点凭空捏造了这次即兴的采访，他有点只是从摄像师身边走过，对着摄像机说了出来。然后这很酷。是的，我真的很喜欢。不，你和他在一起。吉姆鼓起勇气。他要去救前台。他差一点就走到帕姆那里了。就在那时，罗伊站起来说他正在定结婚日期，6月10日。来自埃兹基萨的粉丝提问说，当罗伊求婚时，帕姆是真的高兴，还是她只是深陷其中？嗯，我看了剧本。剧本上写着，帕姆看起来很高兴。所以我把帕姆演得像是真的有点被这个时刻压倒了。你知道，她一直想引起罗伊的注意。我想她太希望他这样对待她了，所以……
She's also invested years into this relationship. And I feel like I feel for her because she's like, all right, we're gonna do it. This is it. Yeah. I think it makes it so much worse, too, because he had his moment on the deck. Yeah. And she was quite receptive there. And then he didn't go for anything. And then here, look how happy she is that she finally, after three years of being strung along. Yeah. And then you could just picture like, oh, maybe I could have made that face on her if I'd said something upstairs. Yes. Yeah. Yes. It's heartbreaking. And then he's mean to Katie. Well, Amy's, first of all, Amy's reaction is so sweet. So sweet. She is, I mean, she's waiting for her moment. She, please propose to her somebody because she's like, oh,
她也为这段感情投入了多年。我觉得我为她感到难过，因为她想，好吧，我们要这么做了。就是这个。是的。我觉得这也让事情变得更糟了，因为他在甲板上有过他的时刻。是的。她在那里相当接受。然后他什么也没做。然后在这里，看看她有多高兴，在经历了三年的感情拖延之后。是的。然后你可以想象，哦，如果我在楼上说点什么，我本可以在她脸上做出那个表情。是的。是的。是的。这太令人心碎了。然后他对凯蒂很刻薄。嗯，艾米，首先，艾米的反应太甜了。太甜了。她，我是说，她在等待她的时刻。她，求求谁向她求婚吧，因为她想，哦，
my God, this is amazing. Yeah. Amazing. And then you're right. Jim breaks up with Katie very abruptly. Ghibby Jenkins actually wrote in and said, Ghibby, Ghibby Jenkins. That's not real name. Come on. First, it's not real. Also, you just rolled into it. Like, I thought it was part of your sentence. You're like, and then Katie, Ghibby Jenkins. Yeah. I was like, is this like a, like a Missouri thing? I'll be Ghibby Jenkins from Dogpatch. Ghibby Jenkins. Ghibby Jenkins says, Jim was kind of a dick to Katie, the entire cruise for no reason, other than he wanted to be with Pam. She's really innocent through all this. And then he just breaks up with her. Also, don't break up with someone on a boat.
天哪，这太棒了。是的。太棒了。然后你是对的。吉姆非常突然地和凯蒂分手了。吉比·詹金斯实际上写信说，吉比，吉比·詹金斯。这不是真名。拜托。首先，这不是真的。另外，你刚才顺口就说出来了。就像，我以为那是你句子的一部分。你是说，然后凯蒂，吉比·詹金斯。是的。我在想，这是什么，就像密苏里州的某种东西吗？我会成为道格帕奇的吉比·詹金斯。吉比·詹金斯。吉比·詹金斯说，吉姆对凯蒂有点像个混蛋，整次游轮都是这样，毫无理由，除了他想和帕姆在一起。经历了这一切，她真的很无辜。然后他直接和她分手了。还有，不要在船上和某人分手。
Well, yeah. There was a lot of the writers said that too, to me. And I thought it was the most efficient breakup you could possibly have pretty much, you know, and we always had time issues. And I just didn't really want to see a long drawn out scene with Katie and, you know, just wasn't about that. And it seemed to me he was motivated to be brusque and, you know. Yeah. He was, he was really upset. He was hurting. He was hurting and he just sort of lashed out. I didn't think it needed to be long. I thought it was perfect. But I also love, and this is something we've talked about a lot, Greg, is that these characters are flawed people. They're not perfect people. So they're going to have moments like Pam was petty. I think
好吧，是的。很多编剧也对我这么说过。我以为这是你所能拥有的最高效的分手了，差不多是这样，你知道的，我们总是时间紧迫。我真的不想看到和凯蒂有一场冗长的拖沓的戏，你知道，这不是为了那个。在我看来，他的动机是生硬的，你知道的。是的。他当时，他真的很沮丧。他在痛苦。他在痛苦，他只是有点发泄。我并不认为它需要很长。我觉得这很完美。但我也很喜欢，这是我们经常讨论的事情，格雷格，这些角色是有缺陷的人。他们不是完美的人。所以他们会有这样的时刻，比如帕姆很狭隘。我认为
Pam has been petty. And my character is certainly, we've talked about my character is certainly, you know, not the nicest person. And you went the longest being not the nicest of any character. Yes. And which was great because then when we got into season nine, and I was kind of casting about for what the arc of season nine should be, it was like, well, there's only one character left who hasn't warmed up at all. Let's put Angela through hell this year. And let her soften just a smidge. Let her deserve a happy ending. Yeah. So then we have a scene where we see that Captain Jack and Meredith are sneaking away to make out, get it on something. Meredith is going to come back later without a shirt on
帕姆一直很狭隘。而我的角色当然，我们讨论过我的角色当然，你知道，不是最好的人。而且你当了最长时间任何角色里面最不好的人。是的。这太棒了，因为当我们进入第九季时，我有点在琢磨第九季的故事走向应该是什么，结果就是，好吧，只剩下一个还没有丝毫变暖的角色了。今年让我们让安吉拉经历地狱吧。让她稍微软化一点。让她配得上一个幸福的结局。是的。所以接下来我们有一个场景，我们看到杰克船长和梅雷迪思偷偷溜出去亲热，搞在一起什么的。梅雷迪思后来回来时没有穿衬衫
and just a life preserver. Do you remember the letter her dad wrote her? Do you remember that letter? Yeah. That said, Dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Thanks, dad. Well, this gives Michael the opening to take the microphone and really start his presentation, which he does by announcing that the ship is sinking. Most of the people don't realize that this is a metaphor, passengers panic, and a man jumps overboard. JT wrote in to ask who was the actual person who jumped in the water. And a lot of people are asking what happened to that person. Yes. Well, that was one of the non-Dunder Mifflin people on the boat. And as I recall, he was not supposed to jump off the boat. As I recall, I mean, I may be blowing this
只有一件救生衣。你还记得她爸爸写给她的那封信吗？你还记得那封信吗？是的。上面写着，亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。谢谢，爸爸。好吧，这为迈克尔提供了一个拿话筒并真正开始他的演讲的机会，他是通过宣布船正在下沉来开始的。大多数人没有意识到这是一个隐喻，乘客们陷入恐慌，一个男人跳进水里。JT写信来问到底是谁跳进了水里。很多人都在问那个人后来怎么了。是的。嗯，那是船上非邓德米夫林的人之一。据我回忆，他是不应该跳下船的。据我回忆，我的意思是我可能记错了
because it was a while ago, but I think there was a little bit of shock that one of the extras jumped off the boat in that take. And I think we were probably not supposed to let him jump off the boat. Well, on the DVD commentary, Greg, you said he really jumped out of the window into the freezing cold water. Yeah. And you said that you always felt bad that there is no like this person jumped into the river. It wasn't on camera. He didn't jump in a boat. He didn't jump in a boat. Like he had to be fished out of the water. There could have been just a rubber dinghy there. I believe it only happened the one time. Yeah, I think so. I think he went, I think he may have either misinterpreted some direction or he just was super enthusiastic. I don't, I have a slight memory of that being a
因为那是很久以前的事了，但我认为其中一个群演在那个镜头里跳下船时，大家有点震惊。我想我们可能不应该让他跳下船。好吧，在DVD评论中，格雷格，你说他真的从窗户跳进了冰冷的水中。是的。你说你总是感到遗憾，因为没有类似这个人跳进河里的镜头。他不在镜头里。他没有跳进船里。他没有跳进船里。就像他必须从水里被打捞上来一样。那里本可以放一艘橡皮艇的。我相信那只发生过一次。是的，我想是的。我想他去了，我想他可能误解了一些指令，或者他只是超级热情。我不，我有点记忆那是
little too gorilla. That's like Kent was out there running that shot. Kent was in the boat that was supposed to catch him, but he went and took the shot. Well, I loved at, so this is around 17 minutes, 34 seconds for my time code people, but I loved that the Dunder Mifflin employees know immediately that there's no emergency. And like, even like Kevin and Angela, like we're in a booth together, Oscar, I guess, is off somewhere being snarky. And we're like, no, no, guys, no, no, there's nothing. Right, you're trying to calm it down. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you pan across all the different Dunder Mifflin employees and they're like, Oh God, here we go. But the rest of the boat doesn't know. Well, this, oh, go ahead. What are you going to say? Well, I'm just saying this
有点太游击作风了。就像肯特当时在那里拍摄那个镜头。肯特在应该接住他的那艘船上，但他却去拍了那个镜头。嗯，我很喜欢在，所以这是给我的时间码听众大约17分34秒的时候，但我喜欢邓德米夫林员工立即知道没有什么紧急情况。而且就像，甚至像凯文和安吉拉，就像我们一起在一个船舱里，奥斯卡，我猜，在某个地方尖酸刻薄。我们就像，不，不，伙计们，不，不，没有什么。对，你在试图让局势平静下来。是的，是的，是的。你镜头扫过所有不同的邓德米夫林员工，他们就像，哦天哪，又来了。但船上的其他人并不知道。嗯，这个，哦，请说。你要说什么？嗯，我只是说这
was leading up to him being handcuffed on the roof. Yes. Yes. And the kind of secret impetus for this whole episode was that, you know, we had come on the air in the first season and we were given, you know, six episodes and we didn't do a great job in the ratings. And there was a lot of question whether we'd get invited back. And so at one point in between the seasons, Kevin Reilly said, come in and, you know, pitch me a new take on the show. Why should I bring you guys back? Oh my gosh, pressure. There was a lot of pressure. And so I had initially kind of thought that the office was such a special, unique show, which I had so much respect for that I wouldn't change very much on it. And I realized that I needed to change something. And I had some experience
是导致他被手铐铐在屋顶上的原因。是的。是的。而整个这一集的秘密推动力是，你知道的，我们在第一季播出了，我们拿到了，你知道的，六集，我们在收视率上没有做得很好。有很多关于我们是否会被邀请回来的疑问。所以在一季之间的某个时候，凯文·赖利说，进来，你知道的，向我推销一个关于这个节目的新看法。我为什么要让你们回来？哦，天哪，压力。压力太大了。所以我最初有点认为办公室是一个如此特殊、独特的节目，我非常尊重它，以至于我不会对它做太多改变。我意识到我需要改变点什么。我有一些经验
with this with King of the Hill in making Hank likable the lead of King of the Hill. And there was, he has certain qualities that were invented to keep him likable. And so I was like, Oh, this isn't really that different. I, you know, because Michael has some negative qualities, and I just got to find a way to give him some stories that are going to warm him up. And so I wrote out a bunch of story ideas somewhere like in probably in norms. No, we weren't at norms yet. That was my go to place in the mornings on Sherman Way and Woodman. But yeah, so I was in some, you know, coffee shop and I wrote down a bunch of moments that I thought would warm him up. And one of them was that, for instance, that the, you know, that even though the staff finds him irritating,
关于《山丘之王》（King of the Hill），让汉克——《山丘之王》的主角——讨人喜欢。而且，他有某些为了保持他讨人喜欢而发明出来的特质。所以我当时想，哦，这其实没那么大不同。我，你知道的，因为迈克尔有一些负面特质，我只需要找到一种方法给他提供一些能够温暖他的故事。所以我写了一堆故事想法，可能在诺姆斯（Norms）。不，我们还没去诺姆斯。那是我早晨在谢尔曼路和伍德曼路的首选去处。但是的，所以我当时在某个，你知道的，咖啡馆里，我写下了一堆我认为会温暖他的时刻。其中之一是，例如，，你知道的，即使员工觉得他很烦人，
they'll back him against an outsider. And so that was like the end of Dundee's. And, you know, one of them was like, he should be good at his job, which happened in the client. He actually was a good salesperson. And, and this one was that he should give a piece of really good advice to somebody that the audience was going to be happy that that advice was transferred, you know, and you'd be like, Yeah, good for you, Michael. And so it was sort of all about him telling Jim to Jim to never give up on the top of that thing. BFD. Yeah, BFD, right? Gage ain't married. Yeah. But that's what the audience wanted to see. You know, Jim was so sad. You wanted somebody to give him some hope and keep this Jim Pam thing going. And so Michael kind of stepped in. And, and I
他们也会在外人面前支持他。所以这就成了邓迪奖（The Dundee's）的结尾。而且，你知道的，其中之一就像，他应该擅长他的工作，这发生在《客户》（The Client）中。他实际上是一个优秀的销售人员。而且，这一个是他应该给某人提供真正好的建议，观众会很高兴这个建议被传达了，你知道的，你会觉得，太棒了，迈克尔。所以这差不多都是关于他告诉吉姆，告诉吉姆在那个东西的顶部永远不要放弃。BFD。是的，BFD，对吧？盖奇没结婚。是的。但这就是观众想看到的。你知道，吉姆太难过了。你希望有人给他一些希望，并让这个吉姆和帕姆的事情继续下去。所以迈克尔有点介入了，而且，我
took the never, ever, ever give up from actually the Winston Churchill speech, which, you know, this is perfectly you. This is so nerdy of me, right? This is perfectly you. Yeah. But like, I always choke up at the speeches of Winston Churchill in World War II and, you know, fight him on the beaches, you know, and he has something where he says, never, ever, ever, ever give in, you know, and I was like, that's cool. I'm going to crib that for, for Michael. Well, it worked and it also worked for me, but like on a different level for Michael, like it works for Jim, but for Michael the whole episode, he just wanted someone to feel inspired by him. Yeah. You know, so when, when Roy announces the engagement, he was like,
把“永不、永不、永不说放弃”实际上取自温斯顿·丘吉尔的演讲，你知道的，这完全是你。我这太书呆子气了，对吧？这完全是你。是的。但就像，我总是听到温斯顿·丘吉尔在二战中的演讲就哽咽，你知道的，在海滩上与他们战斗，你知道的，他有一次说，永远、永远、永远、永远不要屈服，你知道的，当时我想，这太酷了。我要为迈克尔剽窃这个。好吧，它起作用了，它对我也起作用了，但对迈克尔来说是在不同的层面上，就像它对吉姆起作用一样，但对迈克尔在整集里来说，他只是想让某人因他而感到受鼓舞。是的。你知道，所以当，当罗伊宣布订婚时，他就像，
is this because of the talk you and I had? And he goes, no, Captain Jack. And he's like, so you see like Jim's appreciation in this moment. And I feel like Michael feels it. And I'm like, oh, Michael got, got one person. Yeah. It was great because the two plots kind of intersect there for a moment. Yeah. And when Jim first walks up to Michael, as an audience member, I'm thinking, oh gosh, this is the worst person for him to be around right now. I know, I know. He is so vulnerable. He, this is bad. And then it turns into what it is, and it's perfect, perfect. After a few of those, Michael starts to get to be a better lead. Well guys, we did it. We did it. Greg, thank you so much. I want to give a plug. You have a new
这是因为你和我谈话的原因吗？他回答，不是的，杰克船长。然后他就像，所以你看到吉姆在这个时刻的感激。我觉得迈克尔感觉到了。我想，哦，迈克尔拿下了，拿下了一个人。是的。这太棒了，因为这两个情节在那一刻交织在了一起。是的。当吉姆第一次走向迈克尔时，作为观众，我心想，哦天哪，现在这是他身边最糟的人。我知道，我知道。他太脆弱了。他，这太糟了。然后它变成了它本来的样子，完美，完美。经历了几次这样的事情后，迈克尔开始成为一个更好的领导者。好吧，伙计们，我们做到了。我们做到了。格雷格，非常感谢你。我想宣传一下。你有一个新
show coming up called Upload, which premieres on Amazon Prime this April. This is crazy. This is the first show that you have written since you wrote The Finale of the Office. That's correct. I've been working on this for so long. It's kind of, it's kind of ridiculous. We had our strike in 2008 and I was, this was my sort of idea to write a book like a sci-fi book. Okay. And then we went back to work. And so, you know, it was gestating for a long time. And it's sort of a romance, very intense. And it's set in the future. And I am in. I am in. I love sci-fi. I am so in. Well, it's got a very kind of accessible, more Harry Pottery than like on a spaceship kind of deal. And yeah. And I, anyway, so I
节目即将上映，叫做《上载新生》（Upload），将于今年4月在亚马逊Prime上首播。这太疯狂了。这是你自编写《办公室》大结局以来编写的第一部剧。没错。我为此工作了很长时间。这有点，有点荒谬。我们在2008年遭遇了罢工，而我，这是我写一本书的一种想法，就像科幻书一样。好的。然后我们回去工作了。所以，你知道，它酝酿了很长时间。这是一种浪漫，非常强烈。而且它以未来为背景。我加入。我加入。我喜欢科幻。我太加入了。嗯，它有一种非常容易接近的，比在飞船上更像哈利·波特的那种风格。是的。而且我，无论如何，所以I
have been working on it pretty much since the office went down, which is ridiculous. But I wrote it. I sold it to HBO. It was there for a couple of years and then it went over to Amazon and we shot it in Vancouver at the beginning of the year. And yeah, it's finally coming out. I can't wait to see it. I love all of this. These are like some of my favorite movies. And it's a comedy. Yeah. It's funny too. It's a comedy. It's like a lot of stuff. There's a mystery. There's, there's, it's basically there's this idea that in the future, medical imagery will get much better and virtual reality and it will become possible if you're in an accident and you get to the hospital in time to have your brain scanned and then you can be uploaded. It's called upload into a virtual
基本上自从《办公室》结束以来就一直在致力于它，这太荒谬了。但我写了它。我把它卖给了HBO。它在那里呆了几年，然后转到了亚马逊，我们在今年年初在温哥华拍摄了它。是的，它终于要播出了。我等不及要看了。我喜欢所有这些。这些就像是我最喜欢的电影。而且这是一部喜剧。是的。它也很有趣。这是一部喜剧。它就像很多东西。有一个谜团。有，基本上有这样一个想法，在未来，医疗影像会变得更好，虚拟现实也会变得更好，如果你出了事故并且及时赶到医院，扫描你的大脑，然后你就可以被上载。这被称为上载到虚拟
reality hotel that's run by all the big tech companies. So the six big tech companies that have things like Alexa and Siri, they have programmed these luxurious sort of virtual hotels along the lines of different themes. So like the Facebook one is like a casino and the Apple one is like, you know, some sort of beachy kind of resort. And the one that he ends up being uploaded in is like this mountain hotel on a lake. And anyway, that's now did his body die, but then he's uploaded. Do we know, is that a spoiler? No, his brain was scanned. No, I know, but I'm saying is, is it, but that's the end of your head. It burns your head off when, when the scan happens. When the scan happens. So you have died in the real world. Yes. And now you live out the information
现实酒店，由所有的大科技公司运营。所以拥有Alexa和Siri等产品的那六家大科技公司，他们沿着不同的主题编程了这些奢华的虚拟酒店。所以像Facebook的那款就像一个赌场，而苹果的那款就像，你知道的，某种海滩度假村。而他最终被上载到的那个就像湖边的一家山林酒店。不管怎样，现在他的身体死了，但他被上载了吗？我们知道吗，这是剧透吗？不，他的大脑被扫描了。不，我知道，但我说的是，是吗，但这正是你脑子的尽头。当扫描发生时，它会烧毁你的头。当扫描发生时。所以你在现实世界中已经死了。是的。现在你活在信息中
exists and it's digitally presented in a piece of software so that you think you're still alive. I love it. I love it. Upload on Amazon. I can't wait in April. So yeah, guys, if you want more from the man who gave you the office, you have to check out upload. Thank you so much. What a pleasure. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
存在并且它在一件软件中以数字方式呈现，以便你认为自己还活着。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。亚马逊上的《上载新生》。我等不及4月了。所以，是的，伙计们，如果你想要更多来自那个给你带来《办公室》的人的作品，你必须去看看《上载新生》。非常感谢。太荣幸了。谢谢。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西出品。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。有关该节目的无广告版本和我们的彩蛋节目《糖果袋》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。有关Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。